Hey,
you dirty fucks.
We're back.
Yay.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by marijuana.
Let's be honest.
I want,
I was going to have a lot to do with it.
Bulletproof coffee,
marijuana traffic,
this brought to you by traffic.
I was hyped up because of traffic fucking
flying to get over here from talking
to chem trails experts all day.
stamps.com is our
sponsor for this podcast.
Um,
if you have a small business
and you're not using Sam's got,
excuse me,
you have a small business and
you're not using stamps.com.
I want you to check it out because
it saves a lot of bullshit.
It saves a lot of going
to the supermarket.
Supermarket.
You don't go to a post
office at the supermarket,
that'd be convenient here.
Male,
these wives shop.
No,
you go to the post office,
you're gonna have to wait in line and
if you're selling things that you're
sending over,
over through the mail,
it's a long process.
Wayne Shit and labeling it.
You can do all that through
your own home computer.
Simple and easy with stamps.com
it's an awesome service.
If you have your own business,
if you buy any of those little
desk squad t shirts that uh,
Brian cells with the kitty cat on them,
those are all coming
through stamps.com the,
the scale,
um,
that that's included with it.
There's a $110 offer,
$110 value offer.
If you,
um,
if you look in the
upper right hand corner,
stamps.com there's a
little microphone thing,
click on that and use the code word j
r e that's for Joe Rogan experience and
you will get $110 of value.
It's a,
they give you a $55
credit in postage and a,
they give you,
um,
this digital scale that you
don't use for illegal drugs.
You've fucks.
Okay,
this is the government,
this is stamps.com.
All right.
Have some respect.
But uh,
if you're doing something
like Brian does it a desk,
squad.
Dot TV.
It's an awesome way to run a business,
right,
Brian?
Yeah,
it's the only way to do it.
I couldn't imagine having to do it
without stamps.com go into us post office
shit.
It digital scales are pretty bad ass.
Yeah,
they just plug in like know like
a USB cable into your computer.
You know what I think?
I think that this is all just one step
and that in a hundred years from now
you're never going to go
to a store to buy anything.
Everyone's going to have a three D
computer printer thing in your house and
you're just going to make
whatever the fuck you want.
This is not going to be like you'd go to
the apple store because he needed a new
computer.
It's like you get the
whatever your ingredients,
you throw it into your fucking
printer and it makes you a computer.
That's what's going to happen.
So many people have been really pissed
off at me for talking bad about the post
office lately.
I noticed like a lot of male men
are yelling at me and I'm sorry,
I just,
I hate the mail.
To me that's like,
you know,
having a pager,
like I haven't checked the
mail and almost two months now,
which is horrible.
It's a bad idea.
I might open it up and put your drills.
Yeah,
I do most of them online and so I'm sure,
but I'm sure I'll through
there and be like,
fuck,
oh shit.
Oh Fuck Shit.
You know what I mean?
Right.
I just hate the mail.
It's all blurred.
Courtship.
I'm going to jail,
so I know I probably will be anyway,
go to stamps.com
entering the code word j,
r e in the upper right hand corner
where the microphone is and uh,
save his house and kiss ass and $10 value.
That's what was selling.
We're also brought to you by
[inaudible] Dot Com that's o.
N N.
I t.
Um,
if you haven't seen any,
the shit that we have in now,
if you haven't been to
the store in a long time,
it's a,
it's expanding dramatically
on a regular basis,
uh,
between the kettle bells and the
fitness equipment that we started cell
recently.
Um,
of course a litany of different
vitamins and supplements.
Um,
including the ones that
are coming out this week.
I think it's called total primary care.
And they're going to
be like vitamin packs.
I don't think they're,
yeah,
I don't think their facility yet.
But the Kettlebell is back in stock.
Yeah,
we got the chimps back.
We had an order,
a fuck load of them,
but they're there.
They're interesting when they go
fast and the chimp looks like he's,
uh,
he's very scary.
It's very scary.
Chimp.
And so it motivates you while
you're working out Greg Fitzsimmons,
you see that mental chimp and you,
you imagine like what if I'm just
training myself to survive against a real
champ?
Yeah.
My,
my,
my bells or a DX.
I kind of,
yeah,
if guys were coming at me with Cox,
like how hard I would work out.
Right.
You have a strong jaw,
have a strong jaw and um,
you know,
when I bench press,
I actually have a,
it's a cock.
It's giant cock with weights on it.
That actually would be
an awkward thing to lift.
It's probably not a bad idea.
Well,
it has to be stiff.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you try to work out
with a flacid cock bar,
yeah.
You don't want that?
No.
And uh,
do you want a Black Hawk?
What do you want to paint your boards?
I don't want a cock at all.
That's why I'm pushing the weight.
Right.
But what's scary or white
cock or a black hawk,
if you're going to go
with an artificial cock,
it's gotta be black,
right?
Come on,
it's got other worse.
Or you know,
if like Asian people got like super
smart and they got tired of this,
all this little Dick,
you know,
shit that they always hear the tire,
that stereotype.
So they engineer their cocks
to be monstrous and that
becomes the new Har Cock
in the Asian caucus.
Asian caucus just become
like fucking walrus tusks.
Just big giant fat,
murderous.
Right,
right.
You know,
and you know,
they're always trying to
come up with that solution.
That's why it's always like,
it's always like,
you know,
tusks of elephants.
It's always something dangerous.
Then we'll get an Asian man and erection.
They're trying to crack the
code being we have grow.
Why are you killing tigers?
Not only that,
you have Asian women,
they're the hottest
women of all of the rest.
I wonder what it is.
One,
if they're just,
they're just tired of it.
Wonder what it is.
Maybe what and why?
Why would they want to,
I mean,
why would they want,
first of all,
to try all this shit like tiger
bones and where's that coming from?
I mean there's no,
there's no logic to any of that.
Well,
it's a very superstitious,
a lot of Asian cultures
are very superstitious.
Like he'd go to casinos and you see,
you know,
the,
the preponderance of Asian
people gambling is crazy.
Yeah.
And
the way that it's set up,
the way the casinos are set up,
like they've,
they've had like the MGM,
like they used to have a
lion like near the door.
Like you would like go
through the lion's mouth,
let Asians like fuck that.
They don't think lions are cute.
Cause you know,
a lot of Asian countries,
big cats kill people on a regular basis.
And they were so not into
walking through the lines.
Oh yeah,
no,
there's a lot of funkshway type stuff.
About the luck,
you know,
it's bad luck to have red
next to this and yeah,
so they have all these consultants come
in to make sure that it's Asian friends.
Isn't that hilarious?
We got,
should we got,
should we got you.
I understand sir.
You know,
you're not being irrational.
No,
you're not.
You're your fear of the number five or
whatever the fuck it is and you're not
supposed to use,
you know,
like literally if they
see like certain numbers,
it's bad luck and you kind of keep,
keep
track of all that shit.
Meanwhile,
like if you want to get the
American gamblers and just like,
what are we going to do?
Free drinks,
godly.
That should be completely illegal.
The idea that they can boost you up
while you're risking your money and that
there's a benefit in giving you alcohol
for free as long as you're gambling.
Right.
So,
cool.
What a,
what a rude way to go about business.
Well,
you make me get high when
I do your podcast though.
That's not work though.
This is fun for us.
Christ fragments.
He's not bad.
You know,
it's the only time I ever smell good.
It's perfect time.
Why fuck around,
you know,
the,
um,
the uh,
casino in Connecticut,
I just did that won Foxwoods.
So yeah.
And it's like,
I swear to God,
there is more and more of
those little bumper cars.
Every time he got those little scooters
people get on and I start to wonder,
like I,
how often do you see one of those in
real life and then you go to a casino and
every third person is on one.
What's that?
People that are not
making the best decisions.
Yeah.
It draws them those,
um,
things are all over Disneyland too.
I mean,
some of it is people just
whatever they got health problems,
but other ones that just looked like
people that are just fucking lazy fuckers.
The south part,
I think a South Park episode about that.
It's really funny.
Really.
Everyone in the Cartman got one.
Well,
my friend went to Disneyland and uh,
he had,
he'd hurt his hip but the hip was better,
but he asked for one of those carts,
front of the line on every
ride with his family.
Why there's a little tip.
If you're going to Disneyland
and they don't have to,
you don't have to bring
a note from the doctor.
You just,
you just wear it like a,
like a by an ace bandage at a,
at a rite aid,
one of those velcro.
Thanks for your,
yeah,
that's going to give you
really bad Karma Joe.
You know he had weed there the whole term,
right to left you in that jar.
Oh yeah.
Don't know if it's rolling
papers right there.
Right next to your honor.
When I was a grinder.
Yeah.
Fingers.
And I'm not,
I'm not that talented.
We're supposed to be doing commercials.
This,
this commercials over and done.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com oh edited it.
Goodbye some shit.
It's awesome.
Everything is awesome.
Get some new mood,
get your shit together.
Get some five HTP and
[inaudible] system son.
Use a code name Brogan and you'll
save 10% off any of the supplements.
And uh,
that's it.
Do it.
Okay.
Can I can I probably have a,
uh,
next month in San Sacramento,
bringing death squad a show there and
it's going to be meet Sam Tripoli and Tony
Hinchcliffe.
And that's going to get
the Sacramento Punch line.
Uh,
May 3rd and fourth.
And then Sunday,
May 5th,
we're going to COBB's comedy
club in San Francisco.
So a tickets are available at desk squad.
Dot.
TV.
Powerful.
Greg Fitzsimmons is in the house.
Start the music,
let the party.
Well,
the Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Hello powerful.
Greg Fitzsimmons is,
uh,
we're here today for anybody who might
be listening to this in the future.
The Boston marathon
explosion happened yesterday.
It happened right before the podcast,
I think before the one we did yesterday.
We didn't really talk about
it on the podcast yesterday.
Um,
cause I,
I didn't really know what happened.
I was still sort of trying to take
it in and try to figure out what,
you know,
pay attention to what
the store was saying.
Um,
but Greg and I,
uh,
essentially started out our comedy
together and Boston almost like the same
week.
And Greg's going back there this
weekend right after the bombing.
Yeah.
It's a very,
uh,
yeah,
I have very mixed feelings about it.
You know,
obviously going back,
I haven't been,
I haven't worked in Boston and years and
I've been looking forward to this date
so much.
And then this thing happens yesterday
and your first thought is like,
how,
how do you go be funny?
And then you say,
well that's not really the hard part.
I the the easy part is the people that
are going to shell up this weekend need a
laugh.
Yeah.
And are there for that.
What's awkward is to do,
to talk about it before you go.
You know,
it'd be like,
Hey,
come out and see me.
Because a lot of people probably have
bought tickets and I talked to the club
and refunds are available.
If you're not up for coming
out to a comedy show,
it's understood them in.
And if you feel like getting together,
maybe get your mind off
it for a little bit.
We'll be,
we'll be at Nick's this weekend and uh,
making the best of it.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
I'm glad you addressed it.
A Grad,
you put it out there
like that to let them,
let them,
you know,
let them stay home.
I don't know the answer.
That's,
I mean,
I think you have to do that right
when something like this happens,
it seems like a,
to try to pretend it's
just a regular week.
I had a regular show.
You bring it up on stage,
you
think?
I think that,
um,
you know,
this is obviously going to be a
couple of comics on ahead of me.
I'll see.
I'll see what they do and see,
uh,
you know how that feels.
But I don't know.
And I remember after nine 11 I went on
probably maybe a week after nine 11 and I
remember just this feeling of like,
these fucking people were so hungry to
laugh and get their minds off stuff that
it just felt,
I felt gratitude that I could do that,
that in my job,
that's what I do.
And I didn't feel like they've
been listening to pundants
talk about it all day.
And I think that people listen to,
whether it's a minister
or their favorite athlete,
people say,
you know,
moving things.
I didn't feel like my place then was
to be moving and I think my place this
weekend is to be a clown that takes
your mind off it for a little while.
Yeah.
That's a great way of looking at it.
You know,
are Ya,
but I think,
you know,
for whatever reason
you have to address it.
I don't think you reverse without either.
Right.
It is what it is.
I think it's all about like right now,
uh,
what you just said would help people.
Right,
right.
Just it's okay to,
it's okay to laugh,
you know,
there's some really nice chemical
things that happened when you laugh.
There's all this tension that sits inside
of you when an event like this happen,
because we don't know how to,
what's the angle on it?
Right now we're,
we're in the virgin
territory of the story.
There's no like,
this person fucked up.
This agency should have done that.
None of that's out there.
Yeah.
Right now it's just
pure shock and sadness.
Yeah.
As far as what the,
you know,
for the future for anybody listening.
No one knows anything.
It just happened yesterday.
There's no suspects.
They like saw a guy with a hood
apparently and someone had a van.
They were there.
What's that?
Yeah,
they're looking for that black guy.
It's supposedly a nice sweatshirt,
black sweatshirt and black hat that tried
to get into an area he wasn't supposed
to be in five minutes prior
before the bomb blew up.
Oh yeah.
So that's the right thing to do
to saw a girl with a fat ass.
I need to get back to let her
know she forgot her thing.
I got stay right here.
Yo.
He owe me $5 let me get
back there real quick.
Talk to that girl.
Like Boston.
Not always.
Always tough to be a
black person in Boston.
Just got a little tougher.
It's a racist God damn town.
You see this kid?
That's a great town,
but it's racist.
The kid that went to boy that died like
a year ago had like this sign that says
no more hurting people
or something like that.
So sad
fucking craziness,
man.
Two is to juxtapose.
I mean I'm not,
I don't know about you.
I went to the Boston marathon every year.
It's like the most moving thing to see
people that like no matter who you are,
it was a struggle to finish that race.
And for some people it was a
phenomenal journey of you know,
overcoming things,
right?
And you stand there and you watch
people cross the finish line.
It's like elation.
It's like this pure free high
that you get just watching it.
And then to think that that,
that could happen in that same place
just like that and change all those
feelings and it feels like,
you know,
for it to be possible that
something like that happen.
It means they never anticipated
something like that happening.
You know,
for someone to be able to plant bombs
and they don't have security there,
they don't have the whole
area's t sketched out.
They don't,
they don't know who's been in and out.
They're not doing it Israeli style.
Right.
If you're not doing it Israeli style,
you're not going to find down.
And that's where things get really crazy
in this country because it starts to
bring up the,
um,
the ideas about how much
privacy do you really need?
How much privacy do you get to keep when
you're in a situation where people can
just plant bombs,
you know,
that gets really sketching.
People worry about
losing their ability to,
uh,
you know,
to just go through life and not be
intruded upon constantly because,
you know,
now we have to look everywhere because
people were willing to do things like
this.
People are so fucked up that
they're willing to blow up.
Nice folks watching people jog.
So now,
now what do we do?
Well,
it depends.
I mean,
what's the ends of that?
Is it that we want to prevent
it in the future events?
The people that did it?
Yeah,
both.
You want to prevent it.
You want to catch the people who did it.
You want to be able to read everybody's
email because one guy might have an
email,
the,
hey,
meet me at the docks
with the dynamite at two.
I'm blowing that fucking Boston marathons,
Scott High.
You want that guy?
He's got that email.
I sent it out there and I
could see that argument.
You know,
I can totally see it.
I'm uh,
I'm,
I'm the biggest proponent of free speech
and the biggest proponent of civil
liberties.
I think he's not the biggest,
but you know what I'm saying,
a little hype hype,
a little hyperbole or exaggeration,
but I think that when you
have a situation like this,
it really does beg the question,
what do you do?
Like are you,
you have to stay within the rules.
Did you find that person?
I don't think there are rules right now.
I mean after the Patriot Act and
the further erosion of civil rights,
civil rights since then,
you've really got a situation now where
if you don't think that the FBI is
tracking language on
everyone's emails and you know,
they will say it,
you know,
there's no,
this isn't covert.
They say that if you write bomb
and a al Qaeda in an email,
it's going to get flagged and
someone's going to read it.
I did a joke about archive them.
Damn it fucking bombed.
Kind of like comedy.com
is going to blog about it,
which is even worse.
We're paraphrasing
sing,
but he was saying essentially
something about al Qaeda bombing,
right?
We're paraphrase.
Well that's the problem with stand up
is like Louis C k just got shit for you.
Do you see a special,
I haven't seen anyone came out and he,
I guess there's some heat.
I just saw it.
Some gay groups said because he was
talking about pedophiles and he made a gay
voice that it's like this big fucking,
you know,
deal now what's a gay voice?
Really?
It's like this,
but why?
Why?
Why is it,
why is that a game?
Because it's so gay because we've heard
a million guys like that and we're
pretending that there's not a voice.
I'm glad that they get
upset at the gay boys
rather upset about,
they're upset that it is a correlation
between gay and pedophilia,
which is probably not,
it's probably no more,
there's no causality there.
There's no more instances
of gate pedophilia.
Then there is a straight pedophilia.
Really.
Right.
It's across the board
even exactly the same.
Well,
that's interesting.
My family,
I may look outside.
Um,
but getting,
but getting back to the whole,
uh,
civil,
I mean,
I really do think that,
uh,
in the big picture,
how do you stop people from bombing?
I,
one of the things is how the
media handles these stories.
Like I said,
there's no angle on it right now.
There's,
there's a,
a nation coming together in a city coming
together to try to heal and to try to
understand and,
uh,
the,
by the media finding stories that aren't
there and stirring it up and keeping
this at 24,
seven news story,
it gives lunatics us a prize.
And I think we have to be more careful
about that than about trying to snoop and
people's emails.
Yeah,
that's certainly true.
That's certainly true.
And the,
we also have a real mental
health problem in this world,
and the,
the,
the fact that we can
develop humans like that,
that are capable of just killing
a random groups of people,
just a jumble of them together,
just in order to elicit some sort of
reaction to give them some sort of a burst
of excitement.
The fact that we're capable
of producing humans,
but there also were capable of producing
a great Fitzsimmons at the same time
during the same era like man,
like,
oh,
how does,
how do we fix that?
How do we figure out a way to
stop before anything ever happens?
All these people that are
capable of doing disastrous,
horrific things like that because not
everybody's capable of doing that,
right?
It's like who are these the mean?
They must be so far removed from normal.
People have to know.
That means someone has to know.
I really do think are the,
if you look at that Connecticut situation,
you had a guy who was an
outcast who felt unheard,
unseen,
and I think that you aggravate
that to the nth degree.
That's the person that's going to go out
there and try to make some crazy noise.
And I think that in the advent
of a digital environment
where you don't have to
interact with people,
people are going to get lost in the matrix
and they're going to more and more of
seek violent ways or not.
Not necessarily,
but I mean I'm overstating it,
but it does feel like people are going
to get more and more hermit like and,
and I think that that can lead to these
kind of expressions of rage and using
more hermit life because of the Internet.
Is that what you're saying?
I think that's the
direction that kids are had.
I think a kid who normally might've
been called it quote unquote nerd,
still went to the playground and
still played on a sports team.
It's still interacted
more with other kids now,
that same kid,
he comes from school and he will just
interact on websites and through video
games and,
and I think that there's less and less
of a forced interaction with other people
in a healthy way.
I think that's very important for
development for kids getting involved in
activities,
whether it's band or sports or uh,
you know,
being a drama club.
Like anything where you were involved
in activities other than just school.
Right.
And doing things where you're
interacting with people.
You know,
like for most kids,
their day is interacting
with people in school,
wherever it is telling you to be quiet
and pay attention to them for almost the
whole day.
You're taking these
like really hyperactive,
bursting with energy vigils and you
just fucking poisoning them with a seat,
crashing them,
crushing their dreams with Shitty,
boring crap to pay attention.
Memorize.
Yeah.
I mean I've just watched pink Floyd
the wall again recently and Holy Shit,
man,
it's all about that.
It's just about how,
you know,
if you,
you,
the only way to win is to not
follow the rules eventually.
And uh,
but,
but I think that the,
the kids that,
um,
again,
nerds used to have play
dates with each other,
they would meet up and their moms would
drop him off and they were awkward.
A lot of meb low,
you know,
low end Asberger's or
even add or whatever,
learning disabilities that made it
more difficult for them to socialize.
But they did and now they
are just interacting over
the internet and that's not,
that's not healthy.
So it's probably not the disassociation,
right,
that whatever it is that allows people
to go out and just do violence in the UN,
a mass group of just random
people just start killing them,
no connection to them.
Right.
And snipers or whatever it is.
Well,
and also they're saying,
again,
this is the very early stages of
us knowing anything about this,
but that they used a,
a pressure cooker and some simple shrapnel
type material and that you could get
it on.
You could have gotten that on Google.
You could look that up in.
Anybody can look that up in three seconds.
How to make that exact bomb.
So it's not just these people
that are alienated and,
and you know,
angry and obviously a psychotic,
but um,
the ability to assemble things that
didn't exist 2030 years ago is there for
anybody that wants it.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's not hard at all to figure
out how to make weapons.
You can actually get three d plans to
make guns online now for three d printers,
then making plastic guns.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
They only could fire a few times.
I think.
All you need and they start breaking and
this plastic guns they're making on a
fucking printer.
Yeah.
I said,
do you control that?
I think we internet,
I think we need to start
investing in shields and armor.
Then I think we need to
go back to gladiator style
because that's getting worse
and they're the only thing you could do.
It's protect yourself better.
You know,
like we need the force fields,
we eat well you need,
you know,
chain armor.
If you had a walk around
everywhere with a shield,
just a giant hunk of
metal strap to leather
and it's on your forearm and everywhere
you go and you've got a big hunk of
metal.
Like that's how fucked up life used to be.
They used to have to
like have a big plate.
Yeah.
Between you and the world.
Anytime you don't forget,
they were onto something and Capes,
you know,
make it an arm or your whole body is
covered with metal walking around must be
so heavy.
I mean,
how the fuck did those guys move and
go to war with all that shit on start
selling it and on it?
Man,
they probably be so strong.
And then you look at those movies where
they have these five minutes sword
fights with that Shit on David.
Oh my girl.
That sword wants it
somebody and it's like,
all right,
you win sorts of probably
mean how much does it weigh?
30 pounds and be pretty fucking heavy.
Probably like 20 to 30 pounds and that
shape it's probably super awkward.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
But what a workout.
Walking around with armor,
holding swords,
protecting your kids,
the sword around.
That's a serious workout.
Just walking.
How much do you think this shit,
a suit of armor way.
So let's guess before we,
I would probably say a
hundred to 150 pounds.
175 pounds.
Thank you.
Probably about right.
What do you think?
It's closer to 70 it depends on
what era we're talking about.
Oh,
I'm talking like the sexy armor.
Like the big clunky,
big English.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like King Arthur type shit.
Yeah.
I liked the face mask.
That makes a loud noise when you cry.
Yeah.
Right.
Can you imagine?
How could you really hit
somebody with that sword tale?
Did you?
Four miles an hour.
Wow.
It's a lot.
A lot lighter than I thought.
Did you have to poop in those or did
they have like a little buck shit
themselves or its sword fights,
man.
Don't worry about smell like
poop and someone swam a story.
Your head.
It's an advantage.
Shit yourself and keep swinging a,
okay.
So here's the answer.
Um,
the um,
classic harness of plate armor from the
late 14th through the mid 16th century,
varied in weight from 20 kilograms,
which is about 45 pounds
up to 32 kilograms.
So about 65 pounds.
That's exactly the same way as my
Prius in the same way as my cock,
depending on the exact date.
Earlier armor from the 13th and 14th
centuries was heaviest as it included,
uh,
a full,
I don't know how to say this.
H A U.
B e r k Hoover.
Hubert.
How Burke Halberg Halberg of mail
chain mail weren't worn underneath.
Yeah,
that's the stuff I'm talking about.
Yeah.
So they wore the chain mail and then
the more the the armor over email,
um,
I'm trying to,
chain mail is like the thing you
Paul in front of your fireplace.
Yeah.
I think that's,
I think curtain.
Yeah.
I think what they're saying
is that's the heaviest.
But the chain mail must be heavy too.
Well that's a part of that whole sexy
armor that I think of when you're,
hey,
you're not thinking of it like that,
you know,
cone in armor where it's just like
protecting his boobs or whatever,
you know?
Yeah.
So it seems
like they tried to keep it under,
uh,
under a hundred pounds.
They got up to like 65 pounds.
How did anybody ever die in that shit?
Now,
even if you lost the fight,
what's the goal?
Why do I feel like that's bullshit?
I feel like answers.com just
fucked my answers.com it,
that's Jesus as gay brother.
It just seems like they
would be heavier than that,
doesn't it?
When you see those suits that
someone has in their house,
especially when you know,
those are pretty dope.
Put any other layers of
it and then you know,
underneath that,
you know,
they're wearing like a burlap body suit.
Okay.
Here's a serious question.
Is there a guy that has ever existed that
has a full suit of armor in his house
that isn't a douchebag?
Nope.
Well,
I mean,
comic book collector guys
aren't really Douche bags.
You know,
they like that shit.
like they have like what would they
have like a real suit of armor in their
house.
I've almost bought it an
armored helmet the other day.
I saw helmets.
Helmets are Kinda dope.
Yeah.
I almost bought one of
those so I could see it.
I would say last case I would say,
uh,
the same could be said about
those dime store a Indians.
Oh,
cigar story
or the black jockeys that
you put on your lawn.
How about people who have like
little gremlins and shit on there?
The elves,
you know,
what do they call him?
My Step Mama Housing East
on her front porch today.
If it starts to rain,
she puts a rain coat on it.
And then if it's like Halloween,
she dresses up in a little costume.
It's like this big ceramic geese.
And then I,
I was,
I always make fun of it.
And then somebody came broke it
recently and she was so sad about it.
So now she has all these stupid geese
outfits and she can't find another one of
them.
So see,
are you kidding me?
Ceramic.
What happened today?
It was the worst day of my life.
Someone cracked my and McBeard
how you had that one that I leave.
It makes me so happy.
I come home,
I see my several hammock duck.
I got him into Toronto world fairy 62
it's x and they don't make them that much
anymore.
He's beauties.
Oh,
he defined my yard.
I swear you still look at me.
He was my friend.
I know that sounds retarded.
I don't care.
He was my friend
ever since he left.
Ever since Jimmy left,
he's gone.
Oh,
since he's gone.
A house is haunted.
I visited.
He's gone.
I feel a little crazy.
I can't sleep at night cause I feel like
I failed him and he's going to kill me
in my sleep.
I should've,
I should've gotten them a cota armor.
It was my little Chally.
I had a name for forum Charlie
the duck and now he's dead.
I had
illustrated books I made
about him over the is
he's going to come back and
kill those pumps and broke them.
Those fucking punks.
Stephen King movie about a
fucking evil ceramic duck.
That's some good.
Some kids break.
It goes out and cuts their
throat and their sleep.
Just imagine that you wake it
up and a giant ceramic doc.
I just try to throw it out.
Oh I,
I,
I can,
I'm never going to get tired of seeing
the neighborhood punks get beat up for
doing something wrong somehow.
You love that
stores.
Now that book isn't that like the most
scary time of like being a young man is
like dealing with other young men,
especially like guys that are like 14
1516 when you don't know what the fuck
you're doing and you're all
like one up at each other.
Each person is doing the more stupid
than you think we're here with.
Mike did
Crazy.
Yeah.
That's the worst thing
you feel invincible,
young boys without supervision or the
most fucking dangerous things and that's
why the worst is that
there's no fucking jobs.
When I was that age,
I was working,
I was caddying all summer and the winter
time I was like shoveling snow and
fucking painting and then you know,
now they just hang.
That's a very good point.
You know,
and they,
and they don't feel good about
themselves because they're not producing
anything.
So then all of a sudden
like try not doing drugs.
I was working and doing drugs.
Take the work away.
How would have been way more fucked up.
Yeah.
God.
So you have martial arts,
that's all.
I had doses that saved me for sure.
Oh,
I got so lucky if I didn't get obsessed
with that and I just kept hanging around
with all their kids I
was hanging around with.
Right.
Who knows what kind of crazy
show could we got into?
I think marijuana helped me the most
because I would smoke marijuana with my
friends.
Like 15 and we would just try to make
funny tapes up and do things that were
funny because we were stoned.
Right.
You know,
so we were like trying to do Frank Zappa
type kind of recordings and things like
that.
Right.
The trouble it getting stoned
too much as a teenager,
especially a young teenager,
is total emotional under development.
Yeah.
It's a really,
I mean,
no offense Brian.
No,
no.
I mean if I wasn't doing that,
I agree with you 100%.
Right.
Totally right.
No,
he'll admit it.
Yeah,
totally right.
I mean,
my,
all my senses went to art though,
you know,
instead of like learning
about history and crap,
I was just like,
how can I make something cool?
Right.
Well,
it all worked out.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
man.
We're all of us made it sound like he
got a suit of armor and your living room.
Yeah.
These,
uh,
fuck man.
I had friends that died.
I had one guy jumped from a
rooftop to another rooftop,
fell and landed on his head.
Yet Jesus,
we had another guy who was,
uh,
got into a fist fight with another dude,
knocked into a coma dead.
The other guy shot himself,
uh,
shot himself with a shotgun
and other guy was in a car,
put the,
uh,
put a tube from the exhaust
pipe and it was car.
I mean it's not a big town I grew up in,
but it was just fucked up.
There's a lot of drugs.
It was just a lot of intense.
Great.
That's so common everywhere.
It's so common everywhere with young boys.
Yeah.
Like I said,
I avoided all,
but I got super lucky
from the time I was 14 on,
I was just completely
immersed in martial arts,
so I'm,
I barely part of the,
barely hung out at barely socialized.
Did you feel like,
cause kids either feel cool or not cool.
Did you sort of feel not judged one way
or the other because you had something?
Um,
I definitely never felt cool.
I was always insecure.
Even when I was really good at
something like martial arts,
even though that was like the
first thing I was really good at,
I still would get super nervous if I go
to talk to someone at a bank and then I
go to a bank teller.
I get nervous.
I was getting in fist fights
and I wouldn't get nervous,
but talking to a bank teller
and stumble over my words,
you know,
I just,
yeah,
I was,
I was definitely insecure.
I think every kid is,
you know,
the kids,
the kids that aren't are idiots.
If you're,
if you're not,
like,
if you don't look at the entire
possibility of life in front of you,
the entirety of the possibilities,
the massive amount of things
that can or might happen,
not having any idea whether or not
you're proceeding in the right direction,
not having any idea.
If you don't get paranoid,
if you don't get freaked
out looking at that.
If you don't like,
you start thinking about,
you know,
how small a piece you play in this little
thing and how do you figure yourself
out and how do you get through this,
right?
If you don't feel uncomfortable,
if you don't feel insecure,
you're an idiot.
You should feel terrified.
Yeah.
It was like,
remember that movie high fidelity and uh,
Phillip Seymour Hoffman was like the cool,
uh,
I think he was a radio announcer
and he said to the young kid,
he goes,
the kids safe.
I feel like I lose her.
I feel like a nerdy goes kid.
Anybody who was cool growing
up never turned into anybody.
Interesting.
It's so true.
You got to suffer.
Yeah.
It's just reality,
man.
Like you said,
there's no,
there's no way to spin what you're going
through and what your head is trying to
absorb that that leads to
simple answers or security.
Is it in funny
when certain groups that are also
outsiders will decide whether or not one
person or another is worthy of
being in the same outside of group?
Like with standups,
you get that like standups.
I remember a guy seeing Nick Depaulo on
stage once Nick Depalo good looking guy,
you know,
big,
rugged,
handsome guy,
ex football player.
So this was at stitches or at um,
at uh,
fuck.
It wasn't,
it wasn't stitches.
Yeah,
because it moved and
was the second stitches.
I can't Mark Square.
Yeah.
And so he was,
uh,
he was on stage and the car
just like this is not for them.
It's not a standup
comedy is not for jocks.
Not for guys.
Like meanwhile,
Nikki Paulo's a better
comic than you'll ever be.
Top
10 comics of all time.
Wildest imagination.
He's not only a,
I disagree with his politics to a fucking
detail and he's got the worst politics
of all time.
I also think he's my top 10 favorite car.
You know,
how much it takes to overcome disagreeing
with everything somebody thinks and
still think they're that funny.
He was always great.
Oh,
great writer,
brilliant,
brilliant.
But this guy was upset that
he's too good looking right?
Like nick was like a
good looking handsome.
He's Italian beef.
He looked like a football player.
I got that shit in in Boston.
Not that I was big,
but because I was white and
male and I was in college,
I was fortunate child and that,
you know the story.
I went to catch a rising star and
Cambridge and the guy that ran that place,
Robin Horton,
he sat me down and I
auditioned and he goes,
well I can either you didn't pass,
you didn't pass into the club.
He goes,
I can either tell you just you
didn't pass or we can sit down.
I can tell you why.
So obviously I go,
yeah,
what the fuck?
So we sit down and he goes,
as far as I'm concerned,
this is word for word,
I'll never forget this
as far as I'm concerned.
You're just another
cocky little Irish puke.
I was like,
what this supposed to be
from the liberal evolved,
educated Cambridge Voice of good comedy.
And I was like,
that's like the most racist
fucking thing I've ever heard.
Well,
he had a thing,
this guy,
who are you talking about?
He was the,
I would have to say like
the dictator of all,
like all comedy,
right?
Andy Warhol.
There was no alt comedy.
Okay.
All comedy be literally
began to cross comedy.
Yeah.
What David Cross,
I mean there's a lot of people that
like to a attributed to various sources.
I think it all started with cross cause.
Cross was actually funny.
Yes.
Said that a couple of weeks ago.
That's so funny that you say that.
He was funny at it.
He was doing what he wanted to do.
He wasn't like some people were doing
things and you're watching them do it and
you go,
oh this guy's trying to be something
he's trying to put on something.
But Cross was a weird
guy and you get a weird,
I remember he did a thing where he was
onstage and he played an exercise tape
that started talking about stretching
and so he's going through all these
stretches talking about
how he really feels it.
Like where I really feel this.
I really feel like guys,
and it was,
it was so odd and weird,
but it was amusing and it was
amusing because he was enjoying it.
It was like he had such a
brave way of taking these.
Like he had these visions of what,
what was interesting to
him and he would bring,
I remember one time he would,
he did like a four minute set without
saying anything and acting nervous and
then all of a sudden he just like lit up
and scream chicken donuts and the place
fucking laughed for like five minutes.
And I can't explain why.
I mean we've talked about
Andy Kaufman doing weird shit.
Andy Kaufman did a lot of weird shit,
but guess what?
A lot of it wasn't funny.
Sorry.
Comedy nerds,
pedestal going on stage and a sleeping
bag with an alarm clock and laying down
for five minutes on a Saturday night,
catch a rising star.
That's a great story.
It's a horrible experience.
If I paid 20 bucks to see that,
I'd fucking tackle the guy.
But Cross did weird conceptual
shit and it was funny
and he did it all out of this
club that was run by this guy,
Robin and Robin was like notoriously
ruthless and his assessment of comedians
but often like way off the mark.
Well,
a lot of it was a reaction to that.
Boston was so aggressive that the
guys that were successful were tough.
Irish Catholic dudes from Southie,
Dorchester,
and they were talking about gay drinking,
uh,
you know,
stocking about,
every fucking,
you think Boston.
And then this was a reaction to these,
these other comics that were more esoteric
that couldn't really handle crowds,
that were,
they had tasted blood,
they had seen Don Galvin and they weren't
going to watch you guy scream chicken
donuts.
So they created this safe
place to develop these guys,
which is great.
It's just that the way he
curated it was effective.
Right.
I had this in front of me,
told me I was everything
that's wrong with comedy.
I was like,
everything.
I don't even remember.
My bits couldn't be that bad.
And you're so young,
you just,
this is a party.
Oh my God,
he's right.
Well,
he wants to give you that feeling,
right?
He wanted to give you that feeling.
He didn't want to say,
you know,
this is just not,
not your place.
You know,
we're trying to do this here.
We're trying to do that here.
You know,
I think you'd be better
off at another place.
Right.
He didn't have to say that.
I mean,
he didn't,
he didn't go say that.
He said everything that's wrong.
He's a,
he's a bully.
He was a real dickish guy.
Well,
there was the feeling among them that
comedy and comedy is a pretty big
umbrella.
Had to be a certain way,
you know,
and that whatever it was that Lenny Bruce
did and with Carlin did and all that
needed to be protected from
what they saw going on.
Hackery.
Yeah.
Shitty.
Well there was a lot of hackery there was,
and if he was really trying
to promote originality,
right.
But it was also just a scary
guy would yell at people.
He was big,
big dues.
It was intimidating.
Right.
We'd like to get the in your
face and like it wasn't,
it wasn't handled very well.
But I went back,
I went back every three months.
I auditioned again.
He'd say no,
I'd go back for probably
a year and a half.
And then he passed me and
I started working spots.
And like a year later he pulled me aside
and he apologized for treating me the
way he did the first time.
Wow.
You remembered.
Oh yeah.
You didn't have to bring it up.
No,
I didn't.
I was over it already.
I didn't give a shit stereotype too.
He put you into a box and decided to get
defined you and I just know I was like
you back then.
It was like,
challenge,
what do I need to do?
I don't fucking quit.
I just keep showing up,
showing up,
showing up.
You know,
for some reason I had thick
skin.
Yeah,
well you had a determination,
you know,
you,
you had a determination to
make it and you're like,
look,
you know,
you,
especially because you had
been friends with meaning,
you kind of had a good
idea of the landscape.
You're like,
this is not going to be easy.
You got to fucking dig your
heels in and keep moving forward,
but eventually you'll make it right.
I remember you and I
like talking about it.
Like when were,
you know,
just doing open mic nights and shit.
We're talking about making it,
it's like you,
you're going to get through it all and
then one day you're going to get to that
spot and you're going to be a professional
one day and this will all be in the
past.
You just,
it's just getting through it now,
right?
And all these little steps,
you can't look at each one separately.
You got to just the
next night you go bomb,
you know,
providence for no money and the
next night you don't have a spot.
So you go hang around a collab.
When you watch better comics and
you can't on any given night,
stop and look around and go,
what am I doing?
You gotta just keep marching.
Well,
it's also because you're a 21 year old
man at the time and when you're 21 you
don't have much time to like,
you have to make a living.
You're now out of the nest.
Okay,
you're on your own.
And
how much time do you have
to establish a career?
How much time do you
have to get things going?
Well,
you don't have time to sit back and kick
back and relax and not make any fucking
progress like you got to get going now.
Because if I'm going to bail out of
this comedy thing and get a real job,
I don't want to be like starting out as,
as a 27 year old who's given up on comedy
and now it's starting to pursue work
in the real world.
Yeah.
And they'll like,
what have you been doing?
Oh,
but trying to be a comedian.
just suck at it.
You know?
Oh,
worse than saying I've
been in a coma for this.
Well,
I was trying to stand up,
but it just sucked at it.
Well,
didn't you know you suck.
I thought it was going to get better.
Oh,
so you're delusional.
That's not what I'm saying.
Not only that,
but who do you want around the office
less than a guy who thinks he's funny and
isn't,
he's trying to crack everybody
up at that morning meeting God.
But it's,
you know,
it,
it's just like the guys that still either
live at home because they're trying to
make it or they have a,
they have a day job that they,
that they won't give up
cause it's got good benefits.
They're going to take longer to make it.
The guys that just say,
I'm going to live off this shit money.
Because when you're that miserable,
you work harder,
you push yourself harder,
you got to,
you got to paint yourself
into a corner a little bit.
Well you definitely have
to be uncomfortable and
that's something that people
don't like to do,
but in order to grow,
you got to get uncomfortable.
And there's a lot of people out
there that just don't want that.
They want to get as cozy as possible,
as warm as possible,
as quickly as possible and never
get anywhere because of it.
And if you're trying to do something
as difficult as carving out a name and
standup comedy,
you're starting out from the open mic
circuit literally from ready go and you
want to get through this ridiculous idea
that you have that you're going to get
paid to talk to people and you're going
to be able to tour the whole country and
they going to pay to fly
you out from other places.
This is a ridiculous idea.
You have to
be a crazy person.
I know sometimes now when I'm on the
road and I'll see an opening act and you
find out that they're making like $150
for the weekend and like they've got no
health insurance,
they're living out of their car and
then you know what you're making and you
just think this is crazy
that I'm making this.
And that guy who's also on the same stage
also telling jokes is was making 150
and you realize,
oh yeah,
that's,
that's where it starts.
And somehow a few fucking hang in there.
You can get to a point
that it seems absurd.
Yeah.
And let's be honest,
most of those guys don't
deserve to get paid a nickel.
Okay.
They're lucky they're getting 125 bucks.
No,
but some are really good and
they're making shit money.
That's part of the thing.
They'll move up and they'll Marla thing.
Yeah,
and you'll,
you'll be,
might be really good for a month and
then you just fuck it up somehow.
Right?
You can't get it right.
I believe it's a meritocracy.
I really believe that that standup comedy,
if you are good and you work hard,
you will move up period
because there's a need for it.
Everybody,
there's other guys that are moving
up and they're doing movies.
They're not doing standup guys die,
guys leave and there's this constant
need to fill the comedy clubs around the
country to fill,
you know,
managers need new talent that
they can make money off of.
There is always there always looking
for that guy or that girl and it doesn't
matter what you look like,
all that matters is that you've worked
hard enough to figure out what the fuck
you need to do on stage.
Yeah.
To become an actual real professional
is such a long and arduous process.
It was very few people that get through
it and once you find one that that can
actually work,
like you can plug them into your business,
people are always going to be in
the business of live entertainment,
even if it's just for their own enjoyment.
For a lot of folks like that have a
lot of folks with clubs that own clubs.
I mean they actually enjoy
live performance themselves.
Guess they got into it as a,
hopefully that they like it themselves.
If they got into it just
as a business venture man,
it's not a lot of those day.
No.
It's like,
uh,
do you work the Atlanta punchline at all?
Yeah.
Like that.
I mean that dude has had that club for
30 years and when I'm in town he comes
down and he'll watch two or
three shows hang out backstage.
Meanwhile,
he's managing,
um,
uh,
which is really cartel.
He,
yeah,
he's a producer on that.
He's making so much fucking money.
He doesn't need that club.
He loves it.
He loves it and that's
why it's a great club.
It's a perfect setup to,
and it's a time port.
Like if you go in there,
you'll,
you like all of a sudden you're
back in like the 1970s right.
Headshots you see like headshots literally
from the eighties and the nineties
you're like,
oh my God,
there's something cool about those clubs.
Like Nashville's,
Amy's is like that.
Well,
all over the wall I took on my Instagram,
I was put all these pictures,
like one of them was Richard,
Jenny and all these different comics.
A lot of them,
they're dead and gone,
you know,
but that you're seeing them all laid out.
The alcohol,
I forgot about that guy.
Whatever happened to that guy.
And those old clubs like that,
like comedy works in
Montreal and other one,
fuck,
I haven't been there in awhile.
They're amazing.
Yeah,
I just did that a couple of weeks ago.
I mean back when we were in New York,
that was a,
that was a hop,
skip and a jump.
You jump up there for the weekend,
but now in La it's like
Montreal isn't really on the,
that's not really on the tour anymore.
No,
but I do a,
there's a lot of times
as a UFC and Montreal.
Oh,
okay.
So I'll do that the night before.
Craig town in general,
man,
they're so nice up there.
Right?
Isn't it amazing?
It is amazing.
And it's got different personalities.
I think of Canada as a big block man.
You go to Vancouver versus
Toronto versus Edmonton.
Yeah.
It's like the u s they're
totally different personalities.
Very different.
It's a fascinating country.
You know,
it's just,
it's weird how like across the board,
less douchey they are than Americans,
but they're like right there.
I mean,
you're going to have your drunks
going to have your ass holes,
but in general people like more relaxed,
more friendly.
It's,
it's very interesting.
It is.
It's interesting,
but it's almost like when you talked
about getting in and making yourself
awkward,
being in an uncomfortable place
so that you can achieve something.
The problem with Canadians is like,
you can't name more than two stand up
comics that are any good ever that came
out of uh,
Canada,
Harland Williams.
Great.
Stand up.
And um,
who else?
There's another great standup at a,
at a Canada,
Jim Carrey,
but they do good sketch and all that,
but like that voice,
that singular voice,
you know,
calling out against the
status quo and you know,
raging and like that just doesn't
exist there because you know,
I don't know if you want to call
it because it's social ties.
[inaudible] it's too,
I don't know.
Cold should help that shit.
If anything.
Yeah,
it helped in Boston.
Um,
yeah.
Maybe socialized medicine
maybe that fucked him up.
Hate him.
Soft made soft.
Who's today too nice up there
too.
Nice.
And the women,
here's the amazing thing.
Women,
it's very European here in this country.
Women don't want to admit it.
They're fucking second class citizens.
They make 77 cents on the dollar.
They are still,
they still dress up like dirty whores
on the weekends when they go out,
they objectify themselves.
Canadian women are not like that.
It's like on par,
men treat women like friends.
It's,
there's not this gender,
uh,
specific,
behavior up there that
you get in this country.
It's very,
it's very,
it's very European really.
That's interesting.
I never noticed that 77
cents on the dollar still.
Yeah.
But if you do believe in a meritocracy
as far as that concern or you think
there's a conspiracy?
No,
that's what's interesting
to me is like there's laws,
you know,
cause that's,
there's that book out called lean forward
by the woman that runs Yahoo or Google
and,
and she's saying,
you know what the fuck ladies,
the laws are saying you
can't pay us less and you,
you have the same access to degrees.
And you know,
there's the,
there's mothering thing,
there's the fact that
you'd have to mother,
but that's not as much of a
factor now is it used to be.
So it's time for ladies to step up and
fight their way into the board room,
fight,
do whatever the fuck it takes.
They think that women are too nice too.
Yeah.
That they're,
they're team players and that they,
they're lacking the skills that it takes
in a capitalist society to really get
to that next level.
So they're being women.
Exactly.
And the in don't you like women?
This is what I say.
I like them.
I like when they're nice and sweet.
I liked him.
I don't think they should
have to become men.
And when they're doing the same
job as a man and you're like,
you're,
you're trying to call qualify.
Well it depends.
It completely depends on
what kind of job is it.
If it's,
she's talking specifically
about white collar jobs.
Yeah.
But it was a babysitting kids.
Would you rather have a man do
it or did you have a woman do it?
I would rather have a woman do it.
Misses if it's for sure a woman do it.
But then are you generally stronger?
They can do it better
even though it feels Kay.
Um,
if it's a to be a CEO,
I guess whoever's really good at the job,
you know,
when it gets to something like that,
like the,
I think a woman,
like if you're dealing
in the business world,
what could a woman not
do that a man can do?
I mean,
what is,
what is the difference there?
The critical decision making skills.
I mean,
isn't that based on education experience
and how much focus you put into the
business?
It seems to me that that shouldn't
be gender specific at all.
Well,
I think a lot,
a lot of mid management is still sales.
You know,
it's,
it's still the be the
ability to walk into a room,
slap somebody on the back,
tell him you're gonna take up golfing,
you know,
bust their balls and,
make it feel like a boy's club.
I don't tell a big thing.
I don't have any experience in that world.
I don't know anybody like that.
I don't,
I'll never drafted in that world.
So I believe you well,
agents are kind of like that.
Yes.
A little bit.
I know what you're saying there.
Yeah.
They,
they work.
Yeah,
the milk.
Yeah.
And it's hard for female,
you see female development executives,
probably more southern male development
executives and casting because it's,
it is a team effort and it involves,
um,
I think an energy that's very,
that's not as Alpha.
And isn't it interesting that if you're
in one of those situations with those
backslapping buddy buddy
business situations and then
a woman is introduced into
it and the men behave the same
way that they always have,
the woman can actually,
especially if they're
cracking sexual jokes,
the woman could be offended that
they have an altered their behavior,
that they've enjoyed this weird,
unprofessional in quotes,
buddy buddy sort of fuck off relationship.
Like I took her clients out to the Strip
club and bought them steaks and you
know,
we've got this account.
You know what I mean?
Well yeah,
but that's also,
that's her acknowledging that women
should be treated differently than men.
If she's got a problem with
them telling sexual jokes,
then it's admission that there's
two different ways to behave.
There's you,
I'm a woman,
you should behave differently
as opposed to her saying,
cause you know,
I mean a lot of the agents that uh,
art,
we both had the same agent
for a long time and she was,
she was at the Strip clubs with the guys.
Yeah.
And she was a guy,
she was the one landing
all the big comics,
getting all the big deals and
she was the one that could,
she could hang people made sexual jokes.
She laughed harder than anybody.
Did she go crazy?
I'm not sure.
I think she might have went crazy.
But the point is,
it is.
Let's,
my point is you can't do that very low.
Your blow a fucking fuse.
Right.
Well,
it's not a natural female behavior.
Um,
but I see the woman's point of view too,
because if,
um,
let's say the would,
if that was your wife name is and my wife,
it was your wife.
Okay.
And you know,
she was working with a bunch of guys are
told a lot of sexual jokes and it was
just gross.
I don't think my wife would mind
if they were directed at her.
Then there's an issue.
But of course it just happened
to be in the racial jokes.
I don't know.
My wife wouldn't give a fuck.
Boy is they are really bad and gross
and that's inappropriate for anybody,
right?
I mean if,
if the,
if they do that to me,
if I'm at a comedy club and some guy
comes up and he wants to tell a fucking
racial joke in front of me,
don't just say I say nigger because
that's what you wanted to say.
Okay.
How did you know?
I wanted to say,
but really is the,
that is the grossest moment ever when a
guy assumes you are racist and and drops
an end bomb and like looks at you
to see how are you going to react.
And he puts you in a position where
because the people around him,
they're okay with it.
He wouldn't have said it if
it's five buddies run okay with.
So now you're in a position
of being the minority it up,
excuse the pond and saying,
hey,
that's wrong.
Don't like,
you're going to change him.
You're not going to change him.
So you,
so then you got to suck it up and you
got to take that shitty feeling and just
go,
it's not worth it.
It's not worth it.
Especially if it's not funny.
Okay.
Bad One.
It's really funny and racist.
I laugh.
I'm sorry.
I know it's not right,
but I will laugh.
Well,
there's a,
there's shades.
There's sometimes people do it ironically,
but you got to know them to know
that that's not how they feel.
And they're saying it in a really making
fun of people that would make that yes,
but when somebody is doing a straight
up racist joke and you don't know them,
right.
That to me is insulting to me.
Neil Brennan,
you ever hear Neal
Brennan's version of that?
Now?
Neil Brandon,
when he was doing the Chappelle show,
um,
apparently him and his friend started
doing this thing where whenever something
would be in the news,
okay.
He,
they were blaming it on black people.
So it'd be like,
it'd be raining out here.
It's fucking porn out.
He was fucking nigger.
He claims down black people and
it became like this running gag.
Okay.
A Neil.
Brian is probably the least racist
person in the face of the earth.
Yeah.
Not even remotely racist
and he's not serious either.
You fuck like to try to get upset at that,
like anybody that would give
him shit about that is you.
You have to be a crazy
personally and that shit all the time too.
I think that's very common.
People like calling your cat that and
the n word and stuff when no one's around
and like,
you know,
to call you Kathy,
I used that word a lot at all.
Me and animals and maybe I can imagine
if right after you drop an embalm,
the doorbell rings and
you know they heard it,
you open it.
It's a black cop.
Yeah,
but I say funding wise,
no,
no black cop thinks that that is a funny
word when you're talking and they're
ringing your door.
When I yell,
Brandon's getting arrested at that point.
Right.
Everybody's going did your aunt
used to call the gates and words
colored
yellow,
all the colors in this crazy fucking bed.
He's a daddy Khaled bird.
Cassock and lazy.
He hasn't moved from that spot.
Joe,
have you heard of the word dip?
Follia I think it's called.
It's dip.
What is it?
It's when you're born with
two dicks and if there,
if you Google image search to that,
it's amazing.
Like there's guys were walking
to Dick's and it's the crazier,
it's real.
Yes.
It's,
it's actually real of Google search.
Just feel like a guy like
that would be famous.
I know.
No,
that's exactly what I was thinking.
Come on.
How many balls?
I don't know.
I was,
I was just looking@itduringthestamps.com
commercial duplicate.
DUPA wow.
Duplication.
Penile duplication.
It makes perfect sense.
You're,
you're,
you're Adams are all see
yourselves are all splitting.
Oh yeah.
These guys have two dicks.
Whoa.
Dip Ophelia in my mouth party.
If you could own that,
you could have a really cool life.
But if you,
if you shy away from it,
well I wouldn't have this miserable.
Does one get hard to do?
Either of them get hard,
do both,
get hard at the same time.
There's some important
questions there that you know,
because that would suck
if you had one hard mood.
The other ones just dead.
You can even feel it.
And this was like a third ball
that once in a while dripped.
I think it would be like two
rifles on a hunting trip.
You use one and the other ready to go.
Ready to go.
Yeah.
I would just be beaten off
while I was having sex.
Oh double beating off with both hands.
Oh some of these decks look scary.
Like it's like two heads.
It's like one dick,
but it's like a double wide.
The best is,
do you ever like have
an erection and you're,
you're having sex and you can't pop
because you have to go to the bathroom so
bad.
Cause now you could take a leak
with one and keep fucking with you.
Wow.
Or just be on the girl
while you're fucking her.
Don't do that dude.
That's assault.
People get sued.
It would be amazing having
sex with like in her ass.
And her vagina at the same time.
If you could feel both of those,
wouldn't be amazing for her.
She put Jesus Christ bad enough,
this disgusting fuck sticks his penis,
and one way
that's you're less.
She's a super freak and
she really loves you.
It really depends on your relationships.
When I'm trying to say is working
or if they're functioning.
That's the big question.
I'm not really worried about dude,
the decks,
not even a little.
How about that?
He checked out on this topic,
done.
There's the girl with the two vaginas,
the girl,
I think there's at least one
does one of them smell like shit
because I know a few of those.
That's the,
that's how the whole,
well,
I know this woman who
has two uteruses really?
She had the first baby in the first
uterus and that's when they discovered she
had to,
it was lodged in one.
She had to lay out horizontally for like
the last three months of her pregnancy.
Wow.
And then they said,
well,
she wanted to get pregnant again,
and they said,
you should be fine.
It'll probably end up in the same one.
And you're good ends up in the other one,
so she had to go like six
months laying down for that one.
She had double like I forget there was
another organ also that she had a double
of inside of her.
Oh my God.
Crazy Double Oregon's tableau organs.
I know this girl that has every
thing inside of her is reversed.
The current hearts and everything like
this on the wrong side and says she has
to wear this bracelet.
So if she ever,
you know like passes out and have
to do like refurbished or whatever.
Yeah,
they,
they notice on the opposite side.
You mean like her liver,
everything.
The left side of her body
and so the right side,
everything is backwards.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
What is that called?
I don't know.
I've never heard of that
before and she from China.
Crazy.
That's crazy.
Wow.
That would really fuck
that would if you'd say,
wow,
I've never been heard of that die.
How weird is it that the body
can be backwards like that?
How is it?
How weird is it that it's not,
it's called Cyprus at that most bodies
are not completely fucked up and double
dicked and double vagina.
I mean it's,
it's amazing.
It's called situs in versus s.
Wow.
And is it dangerous at all
for the person who has it?
I mean,
she seemed fine.
I think she,
I think I asked the doctor,
I mean I asked her,
I told him to cough.
She said,
yeah,
just everything's in reverse.
No a health consequences for that.
It
doesn't seem like it.
Wow.
I had sex with a girl
with three nipples wants.
Oh yeah,
I did it grow three norms.
Really?
Yeah.
That's really common with a Russian,
the third nipple,
it doesn't look good
cause there's no areola.
So it's kind of a bullshit.
Like I almost went in here to get a
tattoo of aerial around it just to,
where to look.
Look,
it looked like a little,
like a little,
little pimple
without the Areola,
but she had to point it out to me before
we fooled around because it would have
come up.
Wow.
It was not like a mole or whatever.
It was like a nipple.
Yeah.
This,
uh,
this girl I used to work
with on this TV show,
this a guy that she was
dating for a while and before,
uh,
she was dating him.
The guy went on a date
with this agent and,
uh,
they get back to the chick's house and
they start making out and he pulls her
pants down and she has a Taurus
that's like ridiculously enlarged,
like a pinky.
And she tries to explain to him,
she said,
I guess I should tell you about that.
It's like,
I just had this really
just really long clip.
I don't know what it is,
but it's not a deck.
And the guy freaked out and made up some
story about forgetting that he had to
pick up his brother at the airport.
Fucking ran out of there,
like clip was so big that it's scared.
Hermaphrodite.
Um,
I didn't,
I was very,
I was with the girl.
I told you this before,
that when I would go down on her,
like it would stretch out
probably like six inches.
So it felt like I was sucking on a dick.
Just push your lips.
That was a dude.
That was it.
I said it's,
it's actually,
it's stretched out pretty.
I mean,
it was a lot of like,
stretchy,
so bigger than most decks.
I know it would stretch out that it
wouldn't be like that all the time.
Oh,
let's be real.
Six millimeters maybe.
No,
no,
it was,
yeah,
it was like about that.
That's so not
going to get a bigger one.
It was hard.
No,
no,
no.
It's just,
it wasn't,
it was just the meat like the,
you know,
you know what I'm talking about,
like the bubble gum stuff,
but after it's shot,
come out of it,
did it start to get smaller again
after it shaved his beard?
But that's pretty common.
It's called an extended,
uh,
extended clip tours.
I think it's so bad.
[inaudible] that uh,
were the girl rather had it so bad
that the guy just ran out of the room.
Mm.
Since she was hot too.
She couldn't deal.
It was so big.
It just,
you're there,
you're there.
Well not only there,
but why would you make her feel so bad?
You know,
you don't run out because their clits
a little too long for your Weirdo.
Just enjoy this other,
it's pick it up,
move it out of the way.
Like a towel.
He probably thought it was a guy.
Yeah.
But that brings up the question of
hermaphrodites because you know,
it's uh,
it is a technically not a clit.
It is a very,
very small penis.
Her Matt really is.
Yeah.
Well the both.
They've both,
yeah.
Do you stop Brian over to you doing stop?
I think you do.
Yeah.
It stopped.
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
Stop and smile.
You got to realize that.
Stop.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to have sex
with the guy that's also a girl,
unless that's what you really into.
But you've got to decide because if you
do fucker and it's the best sex ever.
Cause also had a cock that's on you,
right?
That's on your head.
Now try chasing that dragon.
Awesome.
Also,
she's the most defined
good human being ever.
So now you feel guilty that you
haven't done the right thing.
Now would it would be her decision whether
or not she identified as a man or a
woman,
right?
If she was a Hermaphrodite,
correct.
Yeah,
she would shoot up or maybe not.
I think most identify as men.
Maybe she would just go all buck angel on.
Yeah,
just identify as something
in the middle there.
It's,
you know,
Buck Angela.
Yeah.
Don't know.
Buck Angel was pull up buck angel.
Please try and find one of us.
All the Middlesex buck angels.
A used to be a woman and a
decided it really should be a man.
So,
uh,
started taking all these
different hormones and looks
like a big beefy man with
a guy who would fight
for king of the cage.
Not like the UFC for like
maybe gladiator challenge.
Look,
see that guy.
All right.
Which one you want when
you want bunk buck.
Angel dating.
Adult.
Aspirational dating,
dating,
dating.
But with hormone shots becomes a man.
Oh,
you have to register.
No one's registered.
You don't want to be on that.
Let me get down there were over the,
underneath the crown.
That guy has a vagina.
We look at,
he's built like a brick shit house.
Big Kick Ass.
Look next to you Greg.
Here's the uncensored version now
over your left side right there.
Wow.
That's impressive.
Yeah.
It's a big yoked up check,
but it's like still a check.
Yup.
You know,
he's in some weird,
strange mid life,
mid world sort of a thing.
Is He,
I guess he's transgender but not,
you know,
it's,
it's like
it's a weird gray area,
right.
Because like until you,
if a man,
a woman,
a man could come,
a woman pretty successfully,
but a woman becoming a man
becomes a bit more complicated.
And I think he's probably,
you mean postop?
I mean,
how do you do,
I don't know what they are doing
these days as far as penises.
I'm not up on it.
Yup.
On this artificial pump up,
uh,
but the artificial penis and a male
to female or female to male rather.
I don't know why.
You just pretty much pull that part
out the clit and you pull it back to
steroids in it.
Doctor ever talked to red bed?
Did you lose your room?
None of us know anything about it.
So pull pulls Clint out
and make it a deck back.
Runs into the break room to get high,
high.
The other real box of paper towels,
Doctor Read Ben,
we need surgery.
I'm not feeling that good.
Can you guys take care of it?
I was listening to you and bird the
other day and you guys are talking about
carving out the taint strip
to make a tea to make a hole.
And it's like the taint strip is like,
you don't know what's under there.
It's like I can basement
cause that you guys,
I don't remember.
That was,
yeah,
it was right.
Yeah.
That's what happens when you get
three hour podcast five days a week.
Yeah,
we get a lot.
The log gets lost.
There's this club called
Middlesex by a [inaudible] is the,
the author's last name.
It's probably the best
novel I've ever read.
And it's about a three
generations of hermaphrodites.
And in the book it's caused by incest,
a brother and a sister
having a child together,
which I don't know if that's true in
real life or it was just in the book.
Oh Wow.
I hope not.
I'm looking at a female to male
transgenders and one of them,
a guy was in the middle and he,
uh,
got pregnant.
He's got a baby.
You mean it was,
he's a female to male transsexual
decided to get pregnant.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I heard about that.
He's looks like a man.
He has a beard.
Right.
Built like a man decides
to get pregnant and um,
he's fucking pregnant,
right?
Yeah.
I remember this.
And he had two kids.
I Dunno.
He's legally married to a woman
who underwent a hysterectomy.
He suspended his testosterone treatments
for several months prior to conceiving
with an anonymous sample
from a sperm bank.
He's doing July.
Wow.
Crazy.
Is that the most had a hysterectomy.
So he being the man decided to
carry the baby and they have a,
a sort of,
uh,
both,
you know,
they have a,
a male female relationship.
Yeah.
It crazy.
And they will,
in the summer they'll give birth to
the most teas child in the Midwest.
Yeah.
Wonder where this is going down.
I think it's in the Midwest.
Is it really getting a second
Wisconsin or some fucking Oh,
Oregon.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
Would you,
what would you do?
You're born,
you're born a,
uh,
you know,
right in the middle.
You'd go either way.
Which way do you go?
Oh,
you gotta be a musician or something.
Just take advantage of it.
Just keep it,
keep it belts.
David.
Both date a musician.
Just go fucking full on nutty.
Yeah.
Just be completely out there
at the end.
Encore.
You come out,
drop your pants and blow people's minds.
Then when they would be that freaked out,
they'd just be grossed out.
Remember that movie junior with Arnold
Schwarzenegger where he got pregnant?
Oh yeah,
that's right.
It doesn't move as worsening.
You got pregnant.
That was the dumbest fucking idea ever.
Man.
He's done some dumb movies.
Yeah.
Twins,
kindergarten,
you cop,
brilliant movies.
The guy became the God damn governor now.
Pretty fucking amazing.
I don't think too many people have
accomplished in one lifetime what he's
accomplished,
but I think that governor stuff was
a just a fucking giant waste of time.
Yeah.
Obviously it wasn't good at it either.
Now it's the ultimate popularity,
you know,
guys like him with like insatiable egos,
they want to be the best.
And then once you've done
the weightlifting and the
movie star politics is the
next level of,
it's all about me and I bet you they
probably do believe they're going to be
able to fix it.
Yeah.
Till they get in there and I go,
oh fuck right.
This is a mess.
Except I think in modern politics,
the best politicians are the
ones that believe they can cause.
The truth is it's not
your policies anyway.
You're not coming in and
rolling up your sleeves.
You're just speaking on behalf of the
group of people that hopefully have some
power.
You know,
you're a cheerleader.
Yup.
You look at a guy like Reagan.
Reagan didn't think of any of that shit.
He just came in and he was an amazing
speaker and he embodied this like Western
male thing that people got behind
Mr Gorbachev tear down that wall.
They became Katharine Hepburn.
You know what a silly old man.
Yeah,
his girl,
a Margaret Thatcher just thought
I re,
I remember the,
with great clarity when,
uh,
all the Iran Contra Shit was going down
when he was testifying that he didn't
remember,
like that was his
560 times.
His defense was that number,
remember?
Wow.
That was amazing times,
man.
Cause that was the first time ever.
And when I was young,
obviously at the time,
but it was the first time in my life
that I realized that the government was
full of shit.
I didn't,
I never figured it out before that.
I never even had a suspicion
that was our water.
Yeah.
I remember watching
Ollie North on TV and uh,
they were talking about selling drugs.
They're talking about selling drugs in
the contras and funding the contras and
the,
and the Sandinistas,
the war against them.
And,
uh,
watching it going.
It was what happened.
Like someone was involved in selling
drugs so that they could get money to buy
guns for people in another country.
Right.
For an illegal war.
Yeah.
And I was like,
what?
What are you even beyond what
you could write into a script?
And then they shred it all the documents.
And we knew they shredded the
documents and they weren't sent to,
well,
Ollie north actually did some time.
Right.
I think he did six months or something.
That's fine.
Um,
I remember I had Ollie North for president
two shirt,
or maybe he got sentenced and then he got
acquitted.
Yeah.
Maybe it was one of those president
things were they pardoned his ass.
Yeah.
Pardon my ass.
He,
uh,
I mean,
look,
they all did that.
They all did whatever the
fucking government wanted them to
do.
And once they established the CIA,
I mean,
that was one of the reasons why they
probably killed Kennedy Johnson.
He wanted it.
He wanted to get the
fucking CIA out of there.
He did not like the fact that it's
from world war two on the CIA.
It'd become like a
whole shadow government,
the government behind the government.
It was like,
what the fuck is this?
What's all this shit?
Did you read the um,
uh,
legend of shadows?
No.
Uh,
uh,
legacy of ashes?
No.
What does that,
the history of the CIA told by a guy,
he wrote it for 10 fucking years.
I think it won the
Pulitzer Prize and it's a,
it's about this guy who,
I can't remember who the writer was,
but he,
this shit was factual and it's about
every debacle that the CIA has been
involved in,
in the history of time.
Everything we've gone into,
we were late getting information to the
fucking Chinese and the Russians are 150
years ahead of us in espionage
and intelligence gathering.
And every time we went,
whether it was the Philippines or I ran,
it was always like a dollar a day,
late,
dollar short and,
and fucking things up.
And,
uh,
and,
and really it was like a,
now you've got the CIA
where it's no longer,
it was set up after World War II as a,
as an agency to collect information
after the Second World War.
And now it's a branch of the military.
They are the ones controlling
the drone strikes.
They're the ones that are sending,
you know,
when we killed Obama,
the pope,
I did,
I just say Obama
killed bin Laden.
That was the CIA.
We basically,
we,
we just,
we can just turn any CIA operative into,
um,
I think they turn them into navy seals,
like with the magic wand.
And then they're allowed
to just go in and uh,
and kill these drones are
ordered by the CIA with no trial,
no transparency.
They can just do it.
Well,
you know about that American,
that was a recruiter for al Qaeda.
He spoke Arabic and he was a,
an American.
And because he was a
recruiter for al Qaeda,
they targeted him with a
drone strike and they got him,
they,
they essentially murdered
an American with no trial.
First Time in history.
Yeah.
That's dark shit.
And the fact that we're like,
well hey,
you know,
and he's sucking not doing
good things over there.
Shouldn't been over
there working with them.
Al-Qaida
and every morning they have a,
they have a strike meeting that,
oh,
that Obama is at where they pick,
they,
it's like a kill.
They,
I think they call it a kill list and they
pick the people that they want to hit
with drone strikes.
None of these people,
none of it is reviewed cause it's all
CIA and they just decide and then they go
kill him without even being on the ground.
Just all through a fucking,
uh,
playstation three app over an
Arizona in a bunker somewhere.
Yeah.
And the success ratio of enemy
combatants and targets to actual innocent
civilians.
It's through the charts.
Oh,
is that right?
Oh yeah.
You mean in a good way?
No,
the wrong way.
The wrong way.
It's kills much more civilians.
Have you never seen these statistics?
It's terrifying.
The drone strikes civilian deaths
and innocent desks versus targets.
It's some insane way now they
hit a wedding the way it's just,
it's way off.
A lot of children,
a lot of children have died.
And it's not that,
it's not that accurate.
It's not that,
I mean there's a lot of people
there then high volume areas,
they're there,
they're shooting at people.
Well cause al Qaeda hides
in cities on purpose.
Yeah.
And also it's like you think about how
my whole thing ever since nine 11 is
capture the guys that did it,
but also protect who we are in the world,
how the world views us as a nation.
You know,
try to control the hatred towards us by
the way we behave like stay part of the
Geneva Convention.
Don't fucking torture
people secretly with that.
You know?
And,
and so part of that is like if you're
in a country and a drone comes in that
doesn't even have an actual soldier
from that other country in it,
and it kills innocent people.
Think about if that
happened in this country,
another country sent a drone
and killed an innocent American,
it would be over.
We would be over there
in fucking eight seconds.
Let's look at what happened in Boston.
Right?
So imagine that was a drone from China,
right?
To kill some enemy combatant
that the Chinese don't like.
I mean,
that's a,
that's a fairly accurate assessment,
right?
I mean,
the numbers of people,
the innocent deaths from drone
strikes are in the thousands.
Yeah,
we had three,
I mean,
not to minimize it,
but it was three people
in Boston and yeah,
you're talking about,
you know,
thousands and thousands of people that uh,
had no trial,
had no recourse.
There was no,
no press coverage of [inaudible].
Yeah.
And it's happening all the time.
And apparently the only
thing that slowed us down,
slowed it down was Patraeus
when portray his cup us.
So they took a couple of weeks off,
right?
Yeah.
Usually had to go through
meetings and see who gets to,
who gets to pull the trigger
on these fucking things.
Now.
Now they just take turns.
Apparently the Pentagon does some drone
strikes and then the CIA does some drone
strikes as well.
This is strikes under
the Bush administration.
How many of you think drone strikes?
Yeah,
you guys
252 the strikes under
the Obama administration.
Oh,
the 500 310
change baby.
Well that's cause it's
way more of them now.
I know.
But everyone to drones back then,
liberals are so woefully inconsistent
on how they criticized Republican
presidents,
especially a black one
for being a warmonger.
Right.
There's so hopelessly inconsistent because
if that was Bush in office and he was
doing this,
there would be democrats that
would be picketing and you know,
we have to stop these drones.
Tracks is horrible drone strikes,
but it's,
it seems like it's more Republicans
that are picketing against,
against Obama.
It doesn't seem like he's
taken a lot of flack from,
from liberals for murdering
innocent civilians with drones.
Now we'll see.
I mean he's got some tests ahead of him
as far as how tough he is on foreign
policy.
You know,
what happens with North Korea,
what happens with,
you know,
if,
um,
uh,
you know,
it's real decides to attack Iran,
those things are going to happen
in the next six months to a year.
Do you think so?
It seems to me like it's overdue.
What's going on with,
with Israel is like,
it seems like it's been
eminent for a long time.
Why do you say that?
Why did you say they can't work it out?
Because the Iranians are not showing
any transparency and they're building
bunkers deeper and deeper into the
ground where you can't detect nuclear,
uh,
um,
the,
the building of nuclear
weapons any longer because it,
they do it all from
fucking satellite sensors.
Yeah.
It's so funny how like
everybody is worried about
new people developing nuclear
power,
but the people that have nuclear power,
you just got to look at them.
We were like,
fuck,
they already got it right.
You know,
like North Korea,
Pakistan,
you know,
you look at India,
any,
any country that has it already,
like,
all right,
they already have it.
You can't say,
listen,
you got to give it back.
You can't have it.
You guys are idiots.
Can we hit?
Yeah,
do it.
Yeah.
Soon it will be like a in America,
like everybody has to carry a gun.
That's the only way to make it safe.
We'll go back to this
cold war thing of like,
well then every country should have
one cause then nobody will ever do it.
But like if Japan tried
to develop a nuclear bomb,
we still wouldn't let them,
even though it was like 60 plus
years ago that we dropped on them,
we've done then then,
then,
then you guys can have that like,
look,
we're,
we're not even upset about that.
We're not even going to retaliate.
Look,
that was 60 years ago.
It was my father's father
was involved in that.
I have no dog in this.
We were kind of being assholes.
We look,
we deserve,
we deserve to beating.
But,
uh,
um,
I would like to have nuclear power.
Please.
I would like to have nuclear weapons.
Come on please.
We won't do anything.
No,
we don't let anybody get them.
That doesn't already have them.
If you already have,
we just go shit.
Right.
That's it.
But I ran.
We don't trust you but you,
you don't trust us,
but you trust North Korea.
That's not what I said.
North Korea.
He has them,
but you can't have them.
Right.
Cause if you,
if you had to choose a student,
what's the more rational government?
You look at Iranians and you look in North
Koreans as much as we want to look at
Iran,
Iran as a being a,
a backwards country.
There's a lot of young people there
that are hip to what the fuck is,
sorry.
It's a very well educated
Friday.
Progressive.
Very,
uh,
it's,
it's not what people like think of
when people think of the Middle East,
especially people that don't have a good
knowledge of what it really looks like
in certain parts of everything's the same.
Everything's a fucking desert.
Camels and shit all fucked.
Right.
But I ran isn't,
is not,
I mean there's a lot of
young educated people there.
Yeah.
So like for them to not have
nuclear weapons and see North Korea,
that's especially under,
that's like some old school,
1920s dictatorship going on there.
I mean that guy is still rocking it the
way people rocked it in the Middle Ages.
He's a real dictator in a digital age.
It is
beyond the fact that he's been
able to control that country with,
I mean once in a while somebody escapes
and it's rare and then they tell you
about,
they're like,
no,
you don't understand.
We all live in little fucking hovels
and were treated like slaves and your
friends tell on you and they're rewarded.
Your coworkers,
your fucking students.
You're in third grade and there's thought
crime where a kid will turn you in and
that's how you grow up
and you and you love.
They say that they're taught in
school like a math problem would be.
Okay,
five American soldiers are on a field.
You killed two of them.
How many left do you have to kill it?
Everything is kill American soldiers.
Yeah.
Wow,
dear leader
and end to fit.
Luckily they don't have that.
They don't have the the rockets to
send that shit anywhere besides stuff.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
Those,
they could send it in to South Korea
and that would just set it off.
Apparently they have just
an insane amount of weapons.
Rockets and Shit just
pointed in that direction.
Just ready to light up if
we don't give them rice.
All right.
That's all this is.
They just renegotiate,
renegotiating their contract.
We give them these nice
fucking little little,
here you go,
shut up for three years and then three
years later they say they're going to do
this.
It's amazing also that with the CIA's uh,
ability to infiltrate
governments and manipulate them.
Third worlds especially,
you know,
economic hitman type situations
and never been able to do anything.
But I'm mother fucker can't get a grip,
can't get it.
China is flood.
China's floating them and
their situation is too nutty.
It's too crazy.
It's too far in.
Like this guy's got a full
iron grip on his populous.
I mean he really has them locked in.
Like you're not going to fix that.
Can you see those troops marching?
They look fucking good.
Yeah,
they are like,
they got some kickass uniforms.
They're in lock step.
It's wild.
Yeah.
You better not be out of step when
you're in the North Korean army now,
which is so weird how some you'll look
at the whole world is like all happening
all at once.
You can get like people in California
on a podcast at the same time,
someone in the jungle of the Amazon
trying to kill a monkey with a stick and
then someone in North Korea
that's a fake crying for the dead.
Kim,
Jon ill,
you know,
I mean,
all of that's happening at the time,
right?
A lot of parts of this world
are just fucking goofy.
Did you see this a 60 minutes at this
thing about the lost boys and they were
from um,
Kenny,
I think or some,
some fucking,
they had to escape war torn Congo years
ago and they walked like a hundred miles
to get into um,
uh,
Tanzania,
that's where it was Tanzania.
And then they got sponsored by a bunch
of Americans to come over because they
were just living in these camps
where they were starving to death.
And so these Christian groups brought
them over and it was tracking these 10
dudes who literally,
they hadn't seen a photograph in their
lives and all the sudden they're brought
to the u s where they've
got a digest TV tray.
Like they got an escalator and
they all fell down backwards.
It was hysterical.
They didn't,
they just all fell over by,
they didn't get that it was moving and,
but then they were like,
the thing that fuck these guys up,
and a lot of them got into drugs and
drinking was what is reality because all
the sudden you say to them,
well,
is there really a man on the moon?
They're like,
oh yeah,
of course it's been a
man landed on the moon.
Well,
but is there,
um,
is there a Batman?
No,
there's no Batman.
So it's like the d trying
to distinguish when you,
when you,
when you haven't thought outside of your
little village that there's been a man
on the moon,
it fucks flux every possibility
up for anything smaller.
Well,
the Batman thing,
like they don't understand fiction.
Is that what it is?
No.
I mean,
Batman's Batman is probably a bad example,
but like that,
there's no such thing as flying saucers.
So you got to teach this person from
scratch that flying sauces are made up and
not real,
not according to your show on Scifi.
But
yeah.
[inaudible] has no opinion.
Got It.
But that there are actual men
that have walked on the moon.
How do you make that distinction
to somebody?
Well,
how do you make this,
how do you explain to them air flight.
How do you explain to the telephones,
how to explain to them,
be able to get a website
on a wireless laptop.
What,
what are you doing?
You're pulling,
Are you getting that picture Amir?
Yeah.
Amir.
Jesus Christ.
It's like a pond but on your wall.
But I have no fish.
Crocodiles going to jump out of it.
Especially as an adult.
I'm trying to look,
put together this culture as an
adult that had no information before.
This is a lot of shit we have
to process on a regular basis,
right?
Yeah.
More so in cities than anywhere.
I went to New York City again last week,
was there for the upfronts.
I hadn't been there in awhile and um,
I forgot,
I forgot how crazy it is.
I forgot how ridiculous it is.
I forgot how long it takes
to get to the airport too.
It's stupid cause they have those old
roads that were invented when people were
on horses.
It's,
it's hard to believe the van Wyck is it
functioning route at this point is a me,
it's maybe the most traveled road in
America and it's a broken down piece of
shit
with no shoulder holes to horrible
puddles.
Every winter new ones,
giant break like um,
or a wheel snapping.
Yeah.
I broke two wheels in
one day once in New York.
I was living in new Rochelle.
I drove in,
I hit a Pothole,
I blew out my fucking tire,
cracked my wheel,
took it off,
threw it out,
put the spare on,
driving home,
blew out and otherwise,
same thing.
Hit these giant holes.
You really need like a fucking,
like a Humvee to travel
back and forth to the city.
When you go through,
when you take,
um,
uh,
it was it 95 when you're
going through the Bronx,
what is that cross Bronx.
Is it 95?
Yeah.
When you're,
when you're taking that
road like good luck.
He better be ready to swerve at anytime
you you'll have a swimming pool in the
middle of the fucking road.
Oh yeah.
And they and the lanes where like they
use bad tar so it got hot in the summer.
Now there's groups at your
tires go into and the trucks,
cause it goes,
it's the Gw bridge is 95 and so you
come off of that and it's suspended,
but it's like fucking,
it's all grooved no shoulder and you've
got people merging on one side and then
they're trying to get off to the left
onto the Deegan within a hundred yards.
It's,
it's chaos and sometimes it's snowing.
Yeah,
right.
Sometimes it's frozen rain and the whole
thing becomes a big ice skating rink.
And if you're going,
if you're going through the Bronx West
and you've got to make that left to go
now to dig in into the,
her down the west side
highway into the city,
you missed the turn.
Yes.
Where you're gone fucking Jersey Pal.
You can't turn around like
15 miles to come back.
And it's like,
so let's try to take you to the airport.
You miss the exit and you've
got to go all the way to Jersey.
You fucking retard.
You fuck a free jar and you're looking
at the traffic on the way back.
It's death.
Nothing but death both ways,
right?
Yeah.
That's a stupid way to live,
man.
It's bad ass though.
It's taking place in the world.
Do you think you could
live in a Manhattan again?
Could you?
Would you enjoy it?
Very much so.
What would you enjoy about it?
Just the being in the center of all the
people to go to a coffee shop anytime of
the day and get the fucking newspaper
and just get some eggs and coffee and sit
there for three hours and
write and look at people,
get on the subway and look at people.
I just,
I like to be pressed
right up against people.
Wow.
That's interesting.
See,
I'm the total opposite.
I like to be on the woods,
right?
To sit on top of a mountain
overlooking a lake.
Just chill.
That's,
that seems to be like,
I think I get plenty out of people
I think is good about Manhattan though,
is that everyone's integrated.
Yeah,
it's everyone's forced
to go in the same stream.
You know?
It's like the can't hop in the Range
Rover's lock the door and avoid black
people like you.
You have to be next to that loud mouth
Puerto Rican girl on the subway
because that's how you get home,
you know?
And you have to deal with all these
different people you'd have to deal with.
And I think that's,
it makes it a more tolerant
place because of that.
You know,
I think people in New York
have a lot of attitudes,
but they also have a tolerance,
you know?
I think so.
I think it's probably the most integrated
place I've ever seen and I don't,
I never felt a lot of racism.
I mean,
I grew up in New York and I
never felt a lot of racism there.
Fuck a little black against white racism.
You did?
Yeah,
I experienced that.
quite a few times.
Is that,
I wouldn't say,
I would say compared to like being in
Boston and places where it's much more
defined like this neighborhoods black,
this one's Italian,
this one's Irish in New York.
The Bronx would like that a little bit.
You've got pockets that
are still self contained,
but for the most part it's um,
it's anybody live in anywhere.
Yeah.
The Manhattan,
especially one of the things being is,
it's so damn expensive to live there.
You know that you're,
you're dealing with people that are
maybe a little bit more educated and more
willing,
you know,
to,
first of all,
if you got to pay to live,
you gotta be,
you gotta be making some good
money to live in Manhattan,
to live well in Manhattan to live.
Yeah.
I mean,
you think about it like an apartment.
Say say you were just a couple,
you'd have to get a one bedroom apartment.
You're not going to get a one bedroom
apartment on the island of Manhattan for
less than probably four or $5,000 a month.
Okay.
And then you got to carry your laundry.
You're not going to have a,
you're not going to have a
washing machine in there.
Yeah.
You're carrying your
shit up and downstairs.
You every time you buy groceries,
you're buying them piecemeal in a corner,
in a corner store for four times
what you pay for in a grocery store.
Yeah.
You're taking cabs all the
time constantly and you know,
it's just,
it's and the taxes.
You get taxed federal state and then
there's a city tax for living in the city.
Used to drive me crazy.
It's like all these other assholes would
come in from Long Island and New Jersey
work in the city,
use up all the utilities and you know,
drive on the roads and then leave.
They didn't have to pay a city tax.
Yeah,
but you want to live there.
Do you want to live there?
You got to pay it.
I know,
but they're using it more than I am.
They're fucking gobbling
it up when they come in.
All these assholes from Jersey littering.
How much was the city tax?
It was,
God,
I don't know the number.
Can you look that it,
it was a lot.
It was like,
I want to say 3%
ooh.
Of Your what?
Your income?
I believe so.
Oh my God.
I could be totally wrong,
but that's what I remember being,
um,
that's ridiculous.
That is,
what do you think about
the flat tax to us?
Well,
you know,
I think it sounds great when people who,
talk about it who are proponents of it,
but then when people would
talk about it and say like,
what are you going to do with that?
With all that less income,
you know,
people are going to suffer.
Like you're going to have to cut a lot
of programs that people count on and it
seems to be the wealthy are more
in favor of than poor people.
Oh of course.
Wealthy would be psyched.
Like,
cause people were talking
about like a 7% flat tax.
I mean those was the last time it
was 14% is that what he came up with?
Yeah,
but whatever it is,
I mean what most people
were supposed to be paying,
it's like 48% Obama,
we paid like 18
no,
but that's adjusted.
He gives 150 150,000 to charity.
So if you were to tax him on the
amount before his deductions,
it was like 30 something percent.
And he said while he ran,
I should be paying more taxes.
He ran on that idea that you should be
raising the tax rates for people like me.
So obviously he's the president.
There's no fucking way he's cutting
corners on paying his taxes.
He's paying exactly what you should you,
you can't expect him to throw
extra in at the end of that.
Like here's a tip,
US
government,
I believe he actually did
like cut his pay because a,
the in solidarity for
something else that's going on.
Sounds familiar.
Some other cuts that are going on.
Right.
But I don't think that you can,
I think if you can criticize,
um,
Mitt Romney,
it was because a lot of his money was
kept in offshore accounts and that a lot
of it was paid through a capital gains.
There was a lot of like shell games going
on in terms of how he was paid through
Shell.
Yeah.
Mitt Romney.
Unbelievable.
He was,
that was so silly.
We almost had a cult member in the White
House and people were so gung Ho for it
just because he was white.
I was driving to California
or to San Francisco.
And you know how you go through a
farm country for a lot of the way,
you know you're going driving
through Bakersfield area.
Steinbeck country as I'm driving up there,
um,
fucking giant Mitt Romney
signs everywhere still.
No,
they were for the [inaudible] still the
queer holding out hope for a recount.
No heat boy.
Did he go away?
Yeah,
I mean Sarah Palin,
she finished up,
she got a job on CNN.
She put out a book.
They told Mitt Romney,
they go get the fuck out.
Go lay low.
We don't want to see you.
Do you think you've seen him
on an interview since it's
probably been humiliated and tired.
I guess it takes a lot out of you,
man.
Obama looked like the age five
years and that election he did.
It's a,
it's a rough,
it must be just the look on his face,
Obama's face compared to like
when he was first in the office.
Like,
he doesn't even be the same human,
he's all gray hair,
you know,
and he just looks like a dude.
He's just got the weight of
the world on his shoulders.
So wife's still looks good.
So there's good.
Yeah.
Keeps it from the truth is that what
he's doing gives us some good Dick and
keeps her from the truth.
It's not a model for marriage.
That's all we need to do.
Sex with the wife yesterday,
Greg for it.
So that's good.
Do,
do,
do you imagine,
I'm asking your wife to do
something as crazy as it be.
The first lady like,
you know,
just like we're all in,
it's not just me being the president.
Like you have to be the first lady.
You can't keep your regular job.
You can't just keep working for xerox
and be the first lady that you gotta be
the first lady.
You're going to have to control every
word you say for the next four year and
the kids,
how do you put your
kids in that situation?
Yeah.
The kids for the rest of the lives
are going to be under secret service
protection.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause then that work that way.
I,
I think they have the option to,
but then you look at like Chelsea Clinton,
she seems to be like a
fucking great person.
All kinds of charity work
and daisy to be great.
And so you could serve as fallen.
You write checks in her house.
I think that sounds like a nightmare.
Yeah.
Oh God.
I wonder if the first time she got laid,
you imagine fucking her being the first
guy to fuck the daughter of a president.
How hard,
cause usually you got to
sneak past her parents.
You've got to find a
place to hook up with her.
You got to borrow a car,
get a condom.
This tuck,
you're beating the secret
service to get away.
You've got to be a stud.
Yeah.
You gotta be a good climber or
you got to bring them hookers.
Yeah.
You've got to give them something.
You got to help them out.
Dave,
there was a movie about that,
but they didn't do it right.
What was the movie?
Uh,
it was with um,
fuck why'd I think there's
probably been a combo,
but there was one with,
it's called first lady,
wasn't it?
There was a movie about the first lady
about her relationship with the secret
service.
Really?
First Kid.
No,
that was some Shitty TV show,
wasn't it?
Is that a movie?
That
first kid?
Sinbad,
let me tell you some.
Mr. Benson.
Sinbad,
you stick.
Oh,
and the history of killing
Sinbad was up there.
Really?
I mean not that they were not then it
was like a crowd that necessarily they
were there to see Sinbad,
but I mean his energy and his salesmanship
crowds lost their shit for sin.
Bad.
I've never watched Sinbad do stand
up maybe on TV for a couple seconds.
Pacing the stage and going
big and the MC hammer pants.
Right.
Does that guy still around Sinbad?
Yeah,
it's still torn.
I've seen it.
I've seen his picture up in comedy clubs,
comedy clubs.
That's a thing.
You move up to theaters.
It's a big jump man.
Cause then someday you
could be back in clubs.
I still do both.
Yeah.
That's the key.
You got to look up the leg in both worlds.
Well I like clubs.
I liked the experience of doing clubs.
Actually better.
You write more material there?
Yeah,
I'll fuck around more.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
this weekend I'm doing a San Jose Improv.
Are you on?
That's like a theater.
That's such a beautiful
Molly doing it Friday night cause
it's a UFC there Saturday night.
Okay.
That's why I'm in San
Jose in the first place.
Yeah.
But I love that club.
That's a great,
cool.
I just did Zane.
He's in Nashville.
Yeah.
Did that recently.
I don't know if I ever did that,
but then I'm like,
you know,
I've got a couple of theaters,
Vancouver Theater and Winnipeg.
I do Chicago theater.
I do,
I do a lot of theaters,
but I also do clubs too.
And I do the clubs on purpose.
Like I decide like it'd be fun to
just go do a club just to fuck around.
It's like just,
I still love that experience,
that intimacy.
Like a 200,
300 seat or something.
Like,
yeah,
I was on the road the last three
weeks and I've been writing like,
I've been so loving just recording my sat,
sitting in a hotel room alone,
fucking just listening,
rewriting,
rewrite things because
you're like a philosopher.
You get to just think about shit you
care about and then bring it on stage.
And I just did such an amazing,
you know,
uh,
we're just so lucky to be able to do that.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
It's the greatest gig ever.
Speaking of waste,
can I plug a couple?
I'm,
yeah,
I'll be at Cap City Comedy Club in Austin.
There's this thing called
the monsoon comedy festival.
I'm going to be there and a
April 24th through the 27th.
And then,
um,
like I said,
uh,
if you,
if you want to get your head out of the,
a shitty situation in Boston,
uh,
we'd love to,
I'd love to be a part of
some kind of communal,
uh,
experience with you in Boston
at Nick's this weekend.
And again,
if you bought tickets and you're feeling
like that's not the place you want to
be,
a refunds are available,
uh,
we will facilitate that.
Um,
whatever terms you want to come
down with will make the best of it.
She almost go on
powerful Greg Fitzsimmons
house letting bitches.
No.
All right.
Right.
Ice House coming up.
Um,
I don't have one there this week.
this weekend I'm doing,
like I said,
I'm doing San Jose and then,
uh,
next week I'm doing a theater
in New Brunswick back in Jersey,
jersey,
dirty jersey,
letting p below.
There's a certain authenticity to the
east coast that I do appreciate it
when I go to visit Jersey.
Crowds are like,
you gotta earn it and
then they give it to you.
Oh yeah.
They're not handing it out.
They have a hard life.
When he got a hard life,
you'll live at Jersey even if
you live in a mansion in Jersey.
I know poor people live in mansions
in New Jersey still in Jersey.
Bitch,
is Diaz coming with you on that?
Diaz is coming with me.
Of course.
I'll go over and then Anya,
when you're there in Vancouver,
it's going to be you,
me and Ari.
We're gonna have some fun up there.
How often do you go up to her?
To Canada?
I've,
I went to a wedding there this summer.
It's for some ever went what to Vancouver.
Oh,
it fell in love with it.
I want to work.
There's a club up there,
but I don't know what it is.
But if you're listening to on her,
I want to fucking work there.
You were just lying about all that
shit you were saying about Canada or,
right,
right.
I've been there now.
I did nice last winter.
I was there and it was fucking ice.
It was ice.
The entire streets was an inch of ice.
Nobody could get around.
And then,
uh,
and then I think I'm doing the
Montreal comedy festival this summer.
Come a year.
Was it just like January?
Oh,
so it must be like 30 below rite.
Yeah.
And it snowed and then it rained and
melted and then the whole thing froze for
the three days I was there.
I was literally like,
they would pick me up and it was like a,
it was a mile away and we
just fish tail the entire way.
But you know what place was jammed because
it's all these guys that work on oil
rigs outside of Edmonton and they got
like cowboy money and they come out at
night and they're like,
my agent was like,
you're going to sell cds after the show.
I was like,
yeah,
probably.
He goes,
bring every single one that you have.
I brought like a hundred cds,
which I usually,
I'll bring like maybe 30.
I sold out after two fucking nights.
Wow.
It was like they just have
cast their thrown today.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It's cold as fuck the Ark.
I talked to some guys that were up
there and they were explaining to me,
they're working on an oil rig all through
the winter and it's always outside and
uh,
you know,
it got 50 gets 50 below.
So I was like,
well,
what do you do when it gets that cold?
He's like,
you can only go out for a couple of
minutes at a time and then you go,
what you do is you pull the truck up
like they're working on like these
electrical systems.
You pull the truck up,
you get out of the truck,
you're fully loaded like
giant gloves and mittens,
the whole thing.
You can't take the gloves off.
You get there.
Then you try to do work as much as you
can fill a couple minutes and then he
jumped in the car for half an hour.
How man?
And they keep doing it.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's why you know if you work,
you could be a school teacher there
and you're making like 80 grand a year,
a hundred grand a year and
you fucking deserve it.
Right.
You don't want to do it when,
when,
when you could literally die.
If you get stuck outside in Boston,
you can get cold.
Yeah,
it would suck.
I guess you could die,
but probably,
Nah,
probably not going to die now.
And it's also the cost of living up there
is because there's so much money to be
made.
Somebody like if you want to
buy like a two bedroom condo,
it's like $1 million Edmonton.
Yeah.
Jesus around nothing.
There's no sites.
There's no lake,
there's no skiing.
It's just flat.
Nothing land.
But it happens to be commuting distance
to where you can be a maid and make six
figures.
I betcha it's insulated as fuck though.
Talia,
the California,
like that was one of the
things that I'd work on this.
Um,
this,
the first house that I had,
I was like,
uh,
I did something to the wall.
So I was trying to fix it
and it was like the snow,
listen,
I didn't even use installation.
Not only that,
but like in Venice,
like it,
it's,
it's not bedrock.
So some stuff shifts in my house.
All the windows are like trapezoids.
So the wind just comes right
underneath the panes of glass.
It's that bad.
Yeah,
it's like a good,
it's a good half inch on each
side of every single window.
And the only thing you could do is rip
out all your windows and put in new ones,
which we were like,
fuck it.
I mean we're not going to do that and
it will fuzzy thing on the bottom.
You know the installation strip things,
they have these things that stick on
the bottom of your window that have
like to just seal it tighter.
Like it's really popular in Ohio where
he gets really cold and when it comes
through your cracks,
so they have like these little
strips that you might run in windows.
Let's put a couple on those
chat,
grow a mullet with that,
but an engine block of my friend.
What do you eat and nothing.
What do you mean nothing?
You eat my cookies.
You Fuck?
No,
not cooking.
There was a cupcake.
You ate the cupcakes?
No.
Cupcake.
Sinner.
God,
you guys are like a married.
We got some delicious cupcakes.
What was the name of the place?
We just give a shout out.
Yeah.
Nothing Bundt cakes.
Nothing Bundt u n d t cakes.
Yeah.
I would say hairstyling salons and and
cupcake shops have the cutest names.
They're brutal.
Yeah.
It's can never be like Bob's bakery often.
Muffin,
honey,
Suzy q's.
You ever have those?
Yeah.
Those will put you into a,
God damn sure.
Call me.
Oh yeah,
they're,
they're like a custom
made a cupcake company.
You know,
they like,
uh,
they,
they just,
they're ridiculously rich
and you bite into it.
It's,
I can't dot.
Yeah.
Can't,
has plans.
I mean,
I really am like that now.
I'm at the point where like,
if I'm going to have a big piece of cake,
I have to think I got a map out.
What do they got planned after this?
Yeah.
Isn't it funny though,
that you're willing to do that just for
that sensation of sugar and sweetness
and richness and moistness and Oh,
a big piece of chocolate cake,
especially with ice cream.
Like,
ah,
why you're doing it.
You're loving it.
You're fucking loving it.
But then after wears off,
what a terrible,
terrible feeling.
No,
and I,
I realized like a year ago,
I'm lactose intolerant and now I'll still
eat an ice cream cone with my kids and
then just rip far like two days
and they get worse and worse.
I get stomach cramps and
I'll still eat an ice cream.
I'm the same way.
I'm saying I still eat ice cream
and stuff and it just makes me shit.
When you think about like how little
time you get pleasure out of that,
I mean you're going to
get pleasure out of her.
Like what is it,
five minutes to eat a dessert if that.
It's like sex after sex.
You're like,
Oh man,
I'm still feeling amazing.
Well,
you don't feel like shit if you do.
You're doing it wrong.
If you have sex and you feel
like you go know a sugar coma,
like,
Oh shit.
Like,
yeah,
what are you doing?
I still feel really good
about having sex yesterday.
Like I felt like this morning I was like,
God,
why do I feel so good?
And I was like,
did you not have a sex with Brian?
Right?
If you're having sex with
a black cloud over my head,
giant dream I have.
I think I just have sex every day,
so it's not a fun thing anymore.
I was like,
all right.
Yeah.
Well maybe do you want it more than,
yeah,
no,
I'm on the road.
I've been to Tony.
I've been on the road for three weeks.
So it's like I come
back and it's like boom,
I'm back,
get to hey,
you know it builds up over the weekend.
Cause like I,
I get so depressed on the road,
I can't even jerk off a lot because the
crash after that to me is black cloud
and now I'm alone in a room.
Why don't you and I just checked on once
you're bringing somebody on the road
with you bring a friend.
I know,
I keep,
you know,
I don't know.
Then it's a whole thing.
It's like I,
I kinda like the local
comics to be able to work.
I don't like to displace
them by bringing somebody in.
And then every time I
try to bring somebody,
it's like they call me,
we'll,
you know,
they're not going to give
me air fare and you know,
I want to get paid this.
And it's like,
well send them their agents and like,
I don't know,
but I should,
because I get depressed.
You need to do something
after the show and you know,
during the day,
yeah.
Somebody to hang out.
I know I went out with you
guys at time and I had a blast.
That was really fun.
Yeah.
That's the way to do it.
The way you're doing it by not
bringing opening acts that's archaic.
Right.
Cause then it's not fun.
Like when we go on the road,
it's like a little party
and we go to Vancouver.
We're not going to be lonely.
We're going to have fun.
We're going to go eat dinner
and party and you know,
we're gonna have some fun.
Do great shows.
You still have time to write.
It's not like,
um,
yeah,
you have time to write.
I write at night.
I always write at night.
I tried to do some writing during the day,
but it's not my thing during the day.
I like to experience Shit.
So I have like a ritual and my ritual
is during the day I fuck off and do
whatever I want to do,
you know,
or work,
if I have a job,
if I have a UFC gig or if I
like working on the new TV show.
But if it's,
um,
at nighttime that's when I write,
I write like between my,
I do my best shit between like
12 and four in the morning.
That's when I just,
I feel like you just got off stage.
Juices are flowing.
Yeah.
It's that.
And also like I feel like
I can concentrate more if I
know that most people were
asleep.
Well,
no,
if that makes sense.
Yeah.
You're not checking your email.
No worried about if your
phone's going to ring.
But it's not sad to say that I don't have
a lot of ideas that I generate during
the day,
but most of those wind
up on notepad and then I,
uh,
you know,
it took that little iPhone application.
I talk into it and then you know,
I at nighttime I go over all the notes.
At nighttime we'll go over the recordings.
I just,
I like to do it,
I like to do it before I go to bed.
I feel like,
I feel like my brain makes the most
sense at the end of the day too.
Like if kind of like I have a better
perspective on things like I think it's
almost analogous to your life.
Like as you get older,
you know,
the,
the older you get,
the more you sort of are wise
to what the fuck's going on.
Well,
even throughout the day I feel like I'm
stupid or in the morning and I am at
night,
you know,
if you asked me some really important
questions or you make me do an important
interview at 9:00 AM I might stumble
through that bitch and who knows what the
fuck outside
warm up for a longer time,
like an old car,
you got to warm that fucking thing out.
Even when I was young,
I remember being stupid in the morning.
It's just dumb.
It's just doesn't work that right.
Good.
Yeah.
You know,
when we did it Newton
podcast the other day,
I felt like that I was like,
my brain's not working.
I need a good three hours.
I need Starbucks in me already.
And you know,
yeah.
It's like there's a process to
ramping up to the point where you're,
you're at 100% I don't
know how those guys,
I mean I do know how,
cause I've done episodes of morning shows,
but I don't know how
God does that every day.
Every day.
Yeah.
I can gear up for it.
I,
I kind of like getting to a city,
taking the challenge,
right.
We're going to do for radio shows in a
row and you go in there and fucking go.
All right guys,
let's,
you've had a lot of caffeine.
I haven't,
but I'll,
I'll ride the wave.
But then to do it for some of these guys,
five hours a day,
five days a week,
and a lot of functions on the weekends.
The weekends they'll do stuff like,
uh,
it's wacky.
Bob's sideshow giveaway,
the bull ranch.
Fuckhead
yeah,
I've got a mattress,
salads I acid tonight because
they're not making shit on the radio.
So that's how they make their money.
I was listening to a radio
on the way over here.
I rarely listen to regular radio,
but it was a woman who was on and she
was talking about some new Ford car that
she got from this thing.
I'm like,
oh,
so that's what they're doing.
Like they're
always plugging that.
Yeah.
She was talking about this car
that she got from this deal.
I'm like,
well that's how,
I guess that's how you got to do it.
Right.
That's how,
uh,
that's how they make that connection
that you make that advertising dollar.
Yeah.
Well it's,
you know,
um,
fucking hard gig these days.
I Dad did ready on my whole life.
He was,
he was on the air from he that he had a
spot that was 1130 to 3:00 AM you went
in at 1130 in the morning.
He get up.
Oh,
I thought you were [inaudible] 1130 to
three P I thought you were talking p
11:30 AM so he'd get up,
have his coffee,
you know,
we live 25 minutes from the
city and then he'd do that.
Go out for cocktails afterwards in the
city with friends coming home for dinner
or not usually not,
but it was fucking life.
But they paid money back then for radio.
Yeah.
Back then there was no,
you know,
there wasn't that many outlets.
So if you got a Gig and you
are proven to be successful,
like wow,
you had some leverage,
you have some power.
And remember Charles Laquidara chair.
Yeah.
BCN.
And Mark Parenteau.
Yeah,
I emailed with him sometimes.
Yeah.
How's he doing?
He's doing all right.
You know,
just get his head on straight.
Who's a big comedy fan?
Oh,
very supportive.
Yeah,
that guy.
All those guys like the BCN comedy riot.
When we were in Boston,
the number one,
a rock station was WBCN and they had
this BCN comedy riot and every year they
would have this a comedy competition.
And it made a break make was a make or
break situation for a lot of young comics
at the time.
The only way to really move out of being
an open miker into being an an opening
act.
It was huge.
Yeah.
And so,
and you can't,
you can't overstate how
big BCN was in Boston.
It was so much bigger than
the other radio stations.
And they were very generous.
They would put on this,
uh,
what was the thing with the,
the bands to the battle of the bands and
then they do the same thing for comedy
where you'd start out and I mean,
I still have the card,
I got to make a copy of it for you.
It was like the lineup for the entire
Boston comedy riot and it was me,
you,
Todd Parker and Robbie Printz
and Mike Lee and all these dudes.
And I have your name and my name and,
and you know,
a,
and you're kind of competing
against each other.
And the guy that wanted our year I
think was like friendly or running
McMann kind of man.
Yeah.
Brent Mcmahon.
And then um,
yeah,
it's like that was a,
that was the only way you were right.
That was the only way you actually
want up getting like paid gigs.
Like someone would see you
and say you're pretty good.
You know what you do.
You know,
Mc had a,
a local place.
Yeah.
It was amazing times,
ma'am.
Amazing Times.
You were.
Stop,
stop and really think about it.
Yeah.
It's really,
um,
okay.
It's a place in time that doesn't exist
anymore in terms of being able to watch
great comics that weren't
going any anywhere.
You know,
it was like a club here.
We were in a,
in a great fucking club watching,
um,
you know,
guys that were writing true to themselves.
Like,
nobody I've ever seen,
you know,
like a regional voices and uh,
it wasn't homogenized by
having to go to another,
you know,
try to like,
well I'm going to get on the tonight
show or I'm going to get on a sitcom.
Nobody was thinking that way.
They were just thinking about like my act,
what I do on stage and how it can
be different than everybody else's.
And you know what's really
interesting is like there was,
we learn good things and we
also got to see pitfalls.
And one of the big pitfalls that we all
got to see our generation got to see was
the guy that didn't leave.
The guys that stuck around the guys
that were monsters and they were,
there were headlines in this
town but they never broke free.
And those guys just,
they became stagnant and they stopped.
And we also got to see the pitfall
of not writing new material.
Those guys would get 20 minutes and
sharpen that fucking thing down to like a
Samurai sword cause fold
the blade and hammer it,
fold the blade in,
hammering until the point
where like Don Gavin,
we,
he was just,
it was an artisan,
right?
It was just like this guy who had
done this dance a thousand times.
I learned more from that guy
then any comic I've ever seen.
There's something to be said
for being able to do that,
to be able to have an act and have your
timing so good that you could say it
over and over and over and over
and over and over and over again.
It was still hilarious.
Right.
It's still sit in the back of the
room to watch jokes that we knew.
That whole thing about the lobster,
like a or that buffet.
Yeah,
the fucking,
the bib,
like the,
the sneeze guard they
put over the salad bar.
Yeah.
They put out,
they put all the good
shit in the back up front.
You got chickpeas and the back.
The last has given you the claw.
So it was,
it's so hard to explain to people
that weren't a part of that.
Like how magical they,
like people are say,
oh they're going to talk
about the old days again.
Like we,
we got super duper lucky.
We got as lucky as a human being could
get if they want it to be a comedian.
We were,
we were in the born and the right time
and then in the 1960s so that when the
1980 comedy rush came around,
we caught the second wave,
not the first wave.
We got to wash the first wave and then
we caught a second way and catching the
second way.
If you've got to see all the
fucking people that hit the rocks,
you got to see all the people
that get hooked on drugs.
He got to see all the people
that self saboteurs people,
the did the white material,
how agents we're going to treat you.
We got to see Lenny Clarke got robbed
of a $250,000 remember that his agent,
you remember Lenny Clark's agent took
off with like a bunch of different
people's money.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
Lenny lost a ridiculous amount.
A lot of people lost a lot of money.
Yeah.
It was like the,
I forget
the agency's name,
Boston Agency and had his own TV show.
He had a TV show that agency left with.
Yeah,
a bunch of comedians.
Fucking stack of cash.
So we got to see,
I think Seinfeld lost money in that too.
I want to say I made it back.
Well,
we are.
I'm thinking you might.
We all got to see all those,
those things that happened before us,
you know,
and the realizing that a few drank
and drove and lost your license.
You ceased to be a
comedian in New England.
Oh yeah.
Those guys.
That was one of the main things that
made me stop drinking because I stopped
after like a year.
I was like,
I can't fucking this.
I've been lucky so far,
drinking and driving,
but the comedy met too much to,
to gamble.
I was like,
I can't fucking do this.
Yeah.
If you had to do a Gig in Maine and you
needed to get someone to drive you or
five,
six hours and we were in the closers
then either like who drive the closer.
Right.
Okay.
I remember a lot of
those gigs you would get,
whether it was Boston comedy or Dicta
rd or someone you had to like drive the
guy.
You would like pick up guys and drive them
and there was no,
I can remember maybe twice getting a hotel
room and all those years there was no
hotel.
You drove six hours,
so you did the Gig and you drove home.
We'll those gigs in Maine.
Yeah,
he didn't get hotel rooms.
When you worked in the Bangor notes,
only three and a half hour drive.
You Pussy try to bang a waitress
and I spend the night with him,
waitress sleeping your
guard for a couple hours,
get a truck,
stop coffee and power.
Through those moments we drive it home.
You're slapping yourself in the
face just trying to stay awake.
Aw Man.
I did that and then I would drive from
Boston after I'd been doing stand up a
few years,
I started going down in New York and
splitting the weeks I'd spend like Sunday,
Monday,
Tuesday in New York.
I come back to Boston during the weekends
and make some money and I would leave
whatever my show was on Saturday night,
you know,
midnight,
one in the morning,
get in the car,
drive to New York and just,
yeah,
slapping myself in the face window,
open Holland over,
jumping up and down and
somehow making it to me open
a new lane.
Fuck Shit.
Yeah.
That's a terrible feeling,
man.
That is a terrible feeling
when you're falling asleep.
Driving.
Yeah,
and so weird things like
something's happening with those,
those when you're sitting there and you
watching those white lines over and over
and over again,
it has this weird hypnotic thing because
if you just pull the car over and start
walking,
you would not fall asleep.
The same human being,
like just the act of walking
you would be to concentrate,
but sitting in that car and just steering
and touching the gas is not enough.
It's all and the sound.
It's like everything
about it is just like a,
I mean,
think about when you're in a
passenger seat on a trip like that,
you're going to be awake
for about nine minutes.
Yeah,
same experience.
You're going to stay awake and talk to me,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah
ma'am.
Friends would always
conk out and road trips.
That shit was brutal.
Thank God they invited
those that they invented,
those little reflectors that
make bumps on your tires,
that saved a lot of lives.
Ridges on the side of the road and go,
you're fucking up.
You're fucking out.
Gives you a chance,
gives you a chance instead
of just a guard rail,
it's going to make you flip them.
Fly through.
I fell asleep.
Lots behind the wheel crashing.
Yeah.
I was down in,
uh,
one summer I was in Newport and I got
in a fight and I got thrown in jail for
the weekend and then I had to go back
to my court appearance in the fall.
So I borrowed my,
my ex girlfriend's car to go to the
court appearance and I'm out the night
before fucking drinking straight through,
didn't sleep,
get her car.
I drive down to the court appearance.
My friend's dad happened to be
in the DA's office in Providence.
I get out of the,
uh,
I get out of the charges.
It was assault charges,
not assault charges.
Um,
disorderly conduct,
get in the car,
drive back to Boston,
which is,
you know,
good hour and 20 minutes driving north,
completely fall asleep.
I wake up and I'm,
I hit the guard rail twice,
spun out,
hit the back tire of a truck straight
and f like fish that ended up on the side
of the road.
Her car was demolished and
got it towed back to Boston.
It was like,
here,
ex-girlfriend,
here's your wrecked car right
back.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Did you fuck her?
After that.
Yeah,
we went,
we,
we had an,
we had a breakup kind of,
we had a long term,
really nice sexual relationship.
Really,
really quick.
You reminiscing.
It was good.
You probably met her girl,
Cindy.
Do you remember?
Yes.
I remember that one.
That was like a 89 right?
Yup.
My dated or in college.
So then I graduated 89
and we were broken up,
but it was like a couple more years of,
you know,
how can up dude,
dude,
there's nothing better than that.
It's kind of cool when you hook up
with someone that you used to bang.
That happened to me very few times,
but one time it was my high
school girlfriend and we
were both like 24 25 at the
time.
It was way better because like we did it
when we were like 1516 whatever it was.
And now all of a sudden
we're like 25 you know,
and it was,
it was interesting.
She was a woman now,
you know,
just like I was a man,
when we met we were like little kids.
So it was very strange,
you know,
is a nice bond because like you've been
through something together that you
can't,
you can't make that up with somebody
at that age when you had anything with
somebody.
It's still kind of comes up,
talk a little bit.
But she was brutal.
So,
uh,
she was spending the weekend and uh,
I got out of it and I though
I had to get out of it.
I keep,
she was driving me crazy
and my friend called me up.
I answered the phone and
I just started going,
oh my God,
I can't believe I forgot.
Fuck Dude.
No,
I know how important this is to look.
I'll just,
I'll,
I'll come and get you.
I'll come and get ya.
Alright.
And I just made up some crazy thing about,
I had to go with my friend to take him
somewhere and I just had to get away from
her.
She was torturing me.
I felt really bad,
but I didn't feel bad enough
to not go through with it.
I had to get rid of this claustrophobia.
You needed to do that.
She was brutal.
She was,
she was,
I dunno what,
you know,
her deal was like as far as like,
um,
what kind of guys that she was dating,
but she was,
there was this thing that she was
doing where she would like try to get,
if you like this,
she wanted that.
If you wanted that she wanted this.
If you liked the song
that was on the radio,
she wanted to change it to what she liked.
[inaudible] girl.
No,
she was Boston and it was,
it was just,
it was,
it was a weird,
she was pretty,
and then it was a weird,
like she,
you know,
like
thing was,
it was exhausting.
It wasn't fun.
Right.
It was exhausting and it got
to the point where I was like,
okay,
I got it.
It was just too,
she liked that 14 not that much.
No,
but other,
the relationship shifted as we got older
because I graduated high school first
and I was completely lost and,
uh,
it wasn't very successful and
I felt like I was a loser.
I was very insecure and she moved
to another part of the state.
And then,
you know,
I would go visit her and it was just,
it wasn't,
it wasn't really,
you know,
like it wasn't an even
relationship at the end.
I liked her more than she
liked me cause I was just like,
I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
I was getting out of high school.
It was like very traumatic for me trying
to figure out what to do with my life,
you know,
because everything I
really was into it was,
I was excited about had no future.
It's like,
like how much future
is or in martial arts,
you know,
how much futures are in fighting.
Like I did and I didn't necessarily want
to be teaching people for the rest of
my life either.
So it was like really confused.
But then when we met when I was 25 I
was a man and I was secure and I wasn't
that way anymore,
you know?
And I think she was used to the,
the last year or so of our relationship,
she sorta got what she wanted and
got pushed me around a little.
Yeah,
she was,
yeah.
She was also like a single
child to a single mother and uh,
she had this weird thing where she
just wanted to kind of run things,
you know,
I think I dunno or wanted to like,
I dunno just be heard or money.
I mean that not even necessarily be heard
but be the one that gets to push the
button.
I'll see the one that gets can't
be with you because they don't
know how you feel about them.
So they constantly have to keep tension
in the line and you're going to keep
kind of
poking you and testing you.
What was so weird,
there was like an
inflexibility to her demands.
That's a good way of putting it.
Yeah.
It was like she wanted it this way
and this is what we need to do.
And it was like,
oh come on.
Like you're not being very fun like
you can we just like compromise,
have fun.
Figure this out.
Like how about will play one of your
songs and we'll play one of my songs.
It's like I don't want
to listen to this shit.
Turn it off.
Like turn it off.
You're telling me to
turn it off in my car.
You're telling me to turn
the radio off in my car?
Not like,
you know,
it would be super awesome
if you put something on that
doesn't suck like nothing
funny.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
There was nothing,
no silliness to it.
I just remember being in the car and her
telling me to change the station and it
was just like,
this is like so gross.
Like this is like a weird moment.
Like why do you even care?
Like I mean with if I'm in someone's
car and they start playing shitty music,
to me that's an opportunity to just
start laughing and make it funny or shit
music.
I would never like be upset
if it's your fucking car.
I had
this girl who when I was in high school,
I used to,
I used to go to this school that was
like 20 minutes away and the only way to
get there was a giant
big yellow school bus.
And it was all Catholic school girls,
except for me,
I was the only male on the
bus every fucking day until
I finally saved up enough
for a car when I was a junior.
So first of all,
it's a masturbatory fantasy from heaven,
but it was also a living hell because I'm,
it's Zit face,
skinny little boy and all these girls are,
you know,
like they're not talking to me.
And I'd get on the bus and just slink.
And so after like a year,
I started to talk to this one girl.
She was pretty,
and she was like,
what I loved,
she was like olive skinned with black,
thick,
wavy hair and Brown eyes
and a little bit thick.
You know,
she wasn't skinny.
She had a rack and a bike a little.
Yeah.
So I start and it got to the point where
I would get on the bus and she'd save a
seat and I'd sit next
to her and it was like,
oh my,
and you know,
this is when you're jerking off the
second you walk in the door every day.
And so I'm thinking about her
and I never asked her out.
I never had the balls to ask her out.
So we flirt and she
wanted me to ask her out.
And then like we kind of like met up once
at a party and I made out with her and
it was a big,
it was like two years
of thinking about it.
And then like I went off to college and
we kind of kept in touch with back when
you wrote letters to people.
And so we wrote letters and
then I invited her up to,
uh,
to visit.
She was a year younger and she was gonna
stay in my dorm for the weekend and it
was like,
I mean,
just fucking seven Rpms.
I'm out of my shit about what
this weekend is going to be like.
She comes down,
I pick her up at the Greyhound station,
bring it to my dorm room and uh,
and it's,
uh,
it's like a Friday night and me and
my boys are just drinking shots,
Tequila,
Budweiser cans,
eight guys packed in a room,
there's cockroaches were yelling shit
and she's just rolling her eyes and going
like,
oh my God,
you guys are so immature.
And like I saw this girl off the bus,
like for the first time
off the bus in a room,
in a dorm room at a giant
university on a Friday night.
And it was like,
I don't know who this is and I do not
want to spend time with this person and
she's staying with me
for the entire weekend.
So you felt like that or she
felt like that's how I felt.
I mean,
I think that she was,
she was probably really nervous and
overwhelmed about coming up to Boston
University and staying with me.
And I know we fooled around and then she
got upset while we were fooling around,
but was just,
she was freaking out.
It was too much.
Just fooling around,
going to the next level.
And then I just fooling
around with too much.
I think she was probably
a virgin if I was 19.
She was probably 17 or 18.
Wow.
So then I brought it back to grey
hound the next to I was like,
yeah,
you gotta
I had a,
another girl that used to tell him
what to do about and this was uh,
she was older than me.
She was 25 when I was 21.
And uh,
we were,
we were in a car accident together.
Some a old man,
it's fucking t boned us
cause smashed into us.
So I was taking a left
on your side or her side.
Her side.
Nice.
Um,
it don't think it hit the door though.
I think it hit the front of the car.
I don't remember cause
I know she wasn't hurt.
But anyway,
we got out of the car.
Um,
and uh,
I uh,
I,
you know,
go make sure that she's okay.
And then,
um,
I got like a box of shit that I had
in the car because the car was fucked.
It had to get towed.
And she made me throw out my Whitesnake
cassette because I had brought my
Whitesnake cassette from the car.
I like picked my stuff,
but I had in the car,
I got it back home and she
looked at it and she goes,
what the fuck is this?
And I go,
that's my Whitesnake cassette.
She goes,
she goes,
you actually shoot.
She goes,
you saved that from the car?
I go,
yeah.
She goes,
throw it out.
And I go,
why?
And she goes,
cause it's shit.
Just throw it out.
It's like,
all right.
So I threw it out and I stop.
I think about that to this day.
I'm like,
how ridiculous is that?
Like she to her,
it's like I,
she couldn't have a boyfriend
that was listening to a,
I got to say,
Joe,
this is a lot of shit.
I agree with you on and I'll
support you on almost anything.
She made the right time.
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
That's one of those bands that made the
music video before they wrote the song
with Tawny.
Take that clawing around the Jaguar and
dancing and it's the most ridiculous.
The dude,
what was his name?
That Michael Bolton looking dude,
God,
I hope,
I don't know from Whitesnake.
What does it have to call name?
I just remember that's
music videos were like,
you enjoy me,
some white snake music.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
Put a CD on or like an MP three of
Whitesnake listen to if I had to.
I mean,
I don't think I have it on.
Let me check.
No,
I have no,
I don't have it on this computer.
Well,
look,
I'd,
if I had it listen to
journey sometimes I'm sue.
I forgot Whitesnake on this fucking
not bon Jovi then I know that.
I know that you went to see Bon
Jovi live once while I worked there.
Yeah,
there was one.
I was working at great woods.
Um,
I didn't know you then.
I was a little younger.
I remember you telling me about it.
You talked about the,
the first moment he walked
on stage and it was,
and it was like an
explosion and you were like,
you were like,
it was the coolest fucking moment.
And I was like,
I would say that
it was pretty wild.
That was when they were at
the height of their start.
Yeah.
It was at the Great Woods
Center in Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
And uh,
I think when he did,
I was like entering into the facility
when he got on stage and they shot
and it's deafening.
I mean,
the,
the cheers.
How many people were
excited about that song?
This is not nothing that a comic
could never do that tops that.
No.
The thing that when a rock band has a
song that you already know the song and
you want to hear it,
that is a completely different feeling.
Then like,
well,
we get art,
we're disposable.
Our jokes are disposable.
They're only good for a
couple of times maybe.
And then we don't even
want to hear him anymore.
Like you don't want it.
Well,
you don't want to hear guys a,
I seen his act,
you know,
you don't want new,
always new,
always new.
But like if you go to see
the stones and you're like,
what are they singing?
What does this song,
I've never heard this song is this new.
You know,
you want to hear the old shit.
you want to hear Jack
flat jumping Jack Flash.
You want to hear,
you know,
you mind if they collaborate,
another band saw you'd rather go
play a new one.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
You want to hear them cover
song that you already know.
It's familiar.
You've already had an emotional experience
with that song and now all they gotta
do is fucking push the button and that
emotion just opens right up again where
it's supposed to stand up.
It's completely cerebral.
Yeah.
And the music when you're high,
there's nothing like a great
song when you got just,
just enough of a buzz,
not enough that you freaking out,
you know,
paranoid and feeling the chest feeling
weird things inside of your body,
but just enough so that you just like,
just catch a little wave,
just catch a little wave and get lost in
a song that comes in over your headset.
Well,
the headset is a key.
If you're,
if you're high,
the right amount and you got on a
headset and you're listening to,
like when the music's over by the doors
for 11 minutes and you go into a trance
and you start to understand
what each instrument is doing,
or Jimi Hendrix,
it's like,
yeah.
How do you compare that to any
experience could have in comedy.
Yeah.
You can't,
we suck.
We're pieces of shit.
We're just not as good now.
We're bad.
Shatter.
Oh Wow.
And then when I was a comedian many,
many years in the future,
I opened up for Bon Jovi on a van.
Yeah.
Vh One theater in the round thing.
It was a in Brooklyn.
Yeah.
Goats.
It was,
um,
it was this thing where it was a disaster.
I had a deal with MTV and a,
I was supposed to do some,
um,
it's going to be some game show thing.
It's a long,
long,
long time ago.
It didn't pan out and uh,
I think I had like a short term
deal with them or something.
I don't remember what it was.
But uh,
I did a couple of things for them and
one of the things that I did was open up
for a Bon Jovi for VH one and it was me
and a theater in the round and that was
really weird.
I never experienced
were you warming up?
The crowd are part of
the televised special?
Oh No,
no,
no.
I was warming up the crowd.
I wasn't part of it at all.
The only part that I played is uh,
trying to get people that were attractive
to sit close to the stage they like
won it.
It was interesting.
They were trying to engineer the crowd.
They were like asking me as a warmup
comedian to not just warm up the crowd,
but to take some of the people that
were pretty and try to get them.
Oh,
so you weren't doing straight stand up,
it was like entertain them and do this.
Yes.
It was both.
Yeah.
Wow.
In the round
round.
Yeah.
Not only that,
they didn't want anything to do with me,
you know,
why do they want,
they don't want a comedian.
They're not here for comedy.
They're the drool over
Bon Jovi in his band.
And then to make it worse,
it's not even a real show.
It's a TV taping.
So this camera's blocking their view.
They're lit up so they totally self aware.
Yeah.
And uh,
they,
you know,
they still rocked it though.
Yeah.
The girls,
it was mostly women.
It was a,
um,
I think it was called an
intimate evening with Bon Jovi.
I forget what it was called.
Is it unplugged?
It part of unplugged?
I don't believe it was unplugged.
I mean,
they had like a full
arsenal of weapons up there.
They had pretty much everything.
It was just a small intimate show.
So for them it was like the
most awesome thing ever.
But before they could get to it,
they had to endure some shitty comedian
trying to get the pretty ones to sit in
the front of the stage.
Like,
dude,
I,
I opened for a grand funk railroad
at a theater in the round.
And what was the one in Queens?
The uh,
wow.
Westbury music 10 yeah,
yeah.
Just playing music fair.
And that long island is long island.
Yeah.
I can see edge edge of Queens,
Long Island.
So they send me out there and it's
like one of those gigs where it's like,
I'm making fucking 250 bucks and
I get out there and there and I,
and I didn't know his
theater in the round.
So I'm backstage,
I'm my,
where's the stage?
And they're like,
well,
there's no really backstage.
It's like you have to
descend into it like,
uh,
like the,
like a Christian going into
the pit with the lions.
You just,
you run down the aisle onto the stage.
And so they go,
ladies and gentlemen,
are you ready for grand funk railroad?
And it's everybody's,
you know,
forties,
50 years old and they're lame denim
jacket wearing fucking losers.
And they start screaming and they go,
but first,
give it up for your opening act.
Oh,
Greg fit.
So I'm running to the stage while 3000
people are booing at me and I get down
there and I pick up the mic and I
start trying to tell jokes and they,
if they're enjoying how
funny it is to Boomi.
And so finally,
just out of pure,
you know,
uh,
just people started respected
that I was actually trying.
So half the crowd stopped booing and then
more him stop doing it and they start
actually listening.
And I was almost doing a show,
but there was that the stage turns,
it actually turns like once every
three minutes it makes a full lap.
So you're like a rotisserie chicken.
And so people would hackle me and then I
couldn't even see where they work cause
I was turning.
And so they were like somewhere else.
And it just went on and
on and then I did my time.
I was like,
I'm getting fucking paid.
I'm doing my 12 minutes
or whatever it was.
And then I ran off stage and I ran up
the aisle and people were like high five
me,
and then they introduce them and it was
like a standing ovation for fucking 10
minutes.
They went crazy.
Oh.
One of the things I said was,
come on,
you've waited 20 years to see these guys.
You can wait another 20 minutes.
You'll get your mother's
station wagon back by middle.
Nice.
Good funk railroad.
I did theater in the round a
couple of years back in Phoenix.
This weird.
Oh,
we're interested in blue.
We just did a special,
I think there and then the
celebrity theater as a,
yeah,
a special.
Really?
Yeah.
It's like 2100 seats.
It's a good move.
Phoenix is,
they're good people.
They're fun.
People did.
Let's turn also like a slowly turned in.
A single might have.
I think that plays,
Carlin did a special there.
That's why Louie wanted to do it.
They're cooked it a lot of giant
like theater in the rounds.
He did like a lot of his,
uh,
his specials I think.
Did he do with the one
in Madison Square Garden?
Was it the theater in the round?
Did you,
did you like doing it in the round?
No,
no.
It's distracting.
Yeah.
I don't want anybody to have to look at
the back of my head while I'm telling a
joke that you want to see my face,
right.
Like that's a shitty seat.
So there's like monitors,
but why do you want to watch a monitor
when the guy was right there and you find
yourself twirling with the monitors here?
I don't even remember
what it was monitoring.
I was like,
it was
that Gig that we did together in,
it was either Seattle
or San Francisco was,
no,
Seattle was almost in the round.
Remember you came out and it was about,
oh,
that was San Francisco.
That was the first night that was
pretty close to theater in the round.
It was like theater and the half around
when I was like at least three quarters.
Half a moon.
Yeah.
That was,
um,
yeah,
that was an interesting spot.
That was the masonic lodge.
Yeah.
That was a masonic exterior.
The fuck it is people who accused me of
being an Illuminati cause I was doing a
show at the masonic lodge.
You fucking please all you knuckleheads
online that think I'm a satanist.
Please stop.
If you're serious,
you silly.
Fuck if you see like it's a serious
to question because now that
you have this show on Scifi,
what's it called?
It's called Joe Rogan
questions everything.
And when does it come out?
July.
Okay.
So do you,
what do you,
what is it like if you were to go
through all the conspiracy theories about
Kennedy being assassinated,
which one do you think is
probably holds the most water?
I just watched a new documentary
about it this weekend.
Did you?
Yeah,
it's called last shot.
JFK.
So the interview,
this guy was a prisoner.
It was,
uh,
worked with Sam Giancana and the mob.
Is it three years ago?
Gives up information as deathbed.
That one.
He,
well he was,
no,
he was actually in prison and
they were interviewing him.
And A,
I don't know why when it came out or why
came out when we put it up right now.
But,
uh,
I thought it was fascinating.
I don't know if he's telling the truth.
Oh,
so what did he say?
Well,
he,
he's,
he believes he,
uh,
his name is James files if I l e S.
Um,
he gives us very detailed
depiction of the crime about,
uh,
how they did what they did,
why they did what they did,
what the motivation was behind it,
and who was involved with and who,
who,
uh,
set the hit up.
And,
uh,
it was a combination with the mob and
the government and they did it because
they wanted to continue
the war in Southeast Asia.
There's massive military contracts and
Kennedy was to deciding that he was going
to pull people out of there and
that he wanted to disband the CIA.
And so they got together and they took
them out and they use this guy who was a,
you know,
a lifelong murderer and gangster,
so,
and so Johnson had a hand in it,
right?
I don't know.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know if this guy knew.
I don't know if he,
um,
I'm a,
I'm,
I'm sure he didn't get to deal with
Johnson or anyone in the high level.
He was a mob hit man,
you know,
so his,
uh,
his story was all the mob side of it all.
Wow.
Yeah.
Pretty believable.
But it's fucking guy who's in jail
for whatever he's in jail for.
He's a bad guy.
He knows what the fuck he dad was a
murderer or whether he shot at a cop who
knows what he did.
But it sounds real when
you're talking to him.
But the reality is no one knows exactly
what the fuck happened except the people
that were there.
But there's all out of Lou Shit.
There's,
there's a lot of loose strings to that,
that case,
including the people who witnessed
the actual assassination themselves.
How many of them died mysterious,
horrible crimes.
And a lot of the people that were eye
witnesses to the Kennedy assassination,
they,
oh,
they died.
And Weird ways,
man.
Yeah,
I'll pull,
I'll pull that up.
Yeah,
the investigation.
Uh,
what was it called?
The,
uh,
the Warren report?
Yes.
A really,
really shoddily done.
And um,
most of it was discredited later.
Have you been following
any of conspiracies
with this Boston thing?
Oh,
I haven't heard a word.
I don't even want to know.
Look at this one night.
It's pretty,
pretty good,
but I think it's pretty easy to
figure it out by like on the,
on the corner of the TV,
see this red,
it looks like blood or a piece
of meat or something right there.
Watching him,
this guy walks by a,
it just like disappears
like a poorly edited video.
Um,
and what's crazy about it is that
if you look for this clip on ABC,
like all the videos on ABC,
it now cuts off right before he walks by.
See how it's gone.
He said that how they used to be a right
thing there and then once he walks by,
oops.
Gone.
And so if you go to,
uh,
like a lot of it
video,
what does that,
what do,
what are people trying to say that is,
I don't know,
like poorly edited video.
So,
watch,
see when you see this guy,
it now,
it just stops.
Like they don't even
show him walk by anymore.
I think shit like this cheapens what
happened when people start putting out
theories about stuff
before we know any facts.
And it starts to then not be about,
um,
the fact that human lives were lost and
well,
no,
I don't even know what
that wasn't the ground.
I mean it might've been one piece of
paper that moved when he passed by it.
Right.
That's what I'm saying.
So I've,
uh,
I've actually found a
unedited video from that,
that,
uh,
shows what it seems to be.
Uh,
and it's,
it's just like a piece of,
of,
uh,
it looks like a flag or a ribbon to watch.
Um,
I think it's coming up right here,
but uh,
right when he walks by,
you could see it like it's
a pulled more pulled out.
Oh Shit.
I don't even remember where it is very,
it doesn't matter.
But anyway,
so yeah,
it was a ribbon.
So like all these people online
are freaking out and like,
like,
oh,
it's,
you know,
a poorly edited video.
That media is tricking us where it just
took me maybe 10 minutes to find a video
that wasn't shit.
Like,
can't you just be a human being for 48
hours and say this was a fucked up thing
that happened.
We have even finding who did
it isn't my first response.
It's like,
why do you,
like you said,
how is it a human being is capable of
this and how do we fucking heal this?
But to all the sudden start to like,
will so it's caused because
of this person or this agency.
It's like,
let it fucking let the bodies cool.
Um,
Kennedy,
by the time a 1967 came along,
103 of the witnesses were dead.
What?
That's crazy.
Seriously?
Yeah.
103.
Well,
is that part of the documentary?
No,
this is another one.
This is another,
this to website depicting the,
the,
uh,
the witnesses for the assassination.
How many of them were,
were supposedly murdered.
When you really look at
who the suspects were,
it's kind of hard to not
say the government when,
when,
when that administration was,
was,
you know,
going through kind of pushing through
the kind of changes that were going on at
that time.
You know,
whether it was civil rights,
which,
you know,
Johnson obviously had no problem with
Kennedy's politics with the civil rights
movement,
but definitely with what
was going on in Vietnam.
Not to put it all in Johnson who does.
Yeah.
Who knows.
I mean there's,
there was a lot of shit going on.
He wanted to get rid of the CIA.
He wanted to get rid
of the Federal Reserve.
He wanted to,
uh,
get,
get American troops out of
Southeast Asia supposedly.
And then there was also people that
were mad at him for the Bay of Pigs.
Right.
You know,
that was apparently a big one that
that one apparently motivated.
I didn't have the juice to do anything,
but it wasn't Castro.
It was the people that
died going over there.
Oh,
the,
those like that made him an enemy of
a lot of people in the intelligence
community.
A lot of people in the military
and a lot of people in the mob.
So there was a,
there was a lot going on,
you know,
the,
there's a lot of people
that didn't like the guy.
I mean,
I think he wanted to be a real president.
And I think by that time they're,
you know,
they had like a whole system and it kinda
had been established and everybody was
sort of playing along with the
rules that they had established.
And Kennedy came along and was like,
what is this CIA and why did they
have more power than the United States
government?
You know?
And then w you know,
and people would fucking cheer
every time we'd get on TV,
they be like,
we got to get rid of this motherfucker.
He's gonna ruin this whole Party.
Meanwhile,
he was much more astute
about international politics
than any of those guys
where he knew he knew his shit and he
knew what was happening in Vietnam and,
uh,
they were afraid of it.
Yeah.
Well they killed him.
He got away with it.
Somehow or another,
they got away with it.
Whoever did it got away with it and
anybody who says that Oswald acted alone,
I've heard those arguments there.
They're preposterous.
They are preposterous and they are the
arguments of a person who doesn't want to
believe in any conspiracies there.
The arguments of a person
who wants to believe it,
listen,
sometimes it's just weird.
Sometimes a guy just lands a headshot
and a moving target from a hundred yards
away.
That is true.
Sometimes that does happen,
but the preponderance of evidence,
if you look at it all points to fuckery.
Most of it in terms of
being a second shooter,
but not just a second shooter
but maybe more than two.
You know,
who knows how many,
but no question about it.
More bullets hit things or were shot
at things then were attributed to the
amount of shots that were taken.
The official record is
if there's three shots.
Well the only reason why they
had to stick with that was,
I mean that's,
that's the only reason why they're
created that whole magic bullet theory.
That's not theory.
That's based on like a rational track.
The trajectory of a bullet and then to
come out in a pristine condition the way
it is.
They did that because they had to make
up for the fact that they knew that a
bullet hit the underpass.
They knew that a bullet hit the curb
stone and ricocheted and fuck this guy's
head up the,
I went to the hospital
and they found the curve.
They saw where the bullet hit,
so they knew that one bullet
had to be attributed to that.
Yeah.
So then those wounds,
you have to figure out how does Connolly
have a wound and Kennedy have a wound
and they're not like lined up,
so it's got a and go down and people say,
well,
you know what?
A lot of people,
strange things happen when bullets,
it hit bodies and sometimes you know,
a little weirder word of it seems,
but sometimes a bullet go,
shut the fuck up.
No.
It would take him like three
seconds to reload that gun.
Yes.
Well,
we'd be quick [inaudible] it was
possible to do within a period of time.
If you were really good and you had
practiced it and you were juiced up with
adrenaline and you were
excellent at being a marksman,
it's possible to do that.
That's not the issue.
The issue is the bullet.
They found that they attribute to this
wacky fucking theory that no one ever
came up with until they found out that
there was a hole in the underpass.
They had to make it.
Oh,
what's maybe it was more than one
person shooting the fuck there was.
There was one person shooting.
He shot three times.
How's that possible?
Well,
I guess the bullet went through both
guys and took turns and fucking and wound
up on the Gurney totally intact.
Even though it's shattered bone,
which has never happened to a bullet in
the history of the fucking human race
and the hospital Connolly's
Gurney [inaudible] rolling
them into the hospital.
Oh look,
we found the bullet.
Yay.
Perfect.
In pristine condition,
like it had been shot
into a sea of pillows.
I mean,
it didn't look like it hit anything.
If you look at that bullet and look at
a bullet that's actually struck anything
that strikes bone when things,
they shattered bones in two
different people's bodies.
It went through Kennedy and then it
went from Kennedy in economy and the
eventually shattered his
wrist through his leg,
whatever the fuck it was.
There was a bunch of people.
Sure.
And then they,
the autopsy was just open and close.
Well,
the autopsy that varies between the,
um,
the way he was described,
the way his body was described in Dallas
than the way his body was described in
Bethesda,
Maryland.
Two completely different descriptions.
They had generals hovering over
the doctors while they worked,
you know,
telling them what to do to talk to us who,
uh,
talked about the like years and years
later that talked about the autopsy.
We talked about how tense
the environment was.
Not Crazy.
It was,
you know,
the is fucking dead was blown apart.
Meanwhile,
you have Johnson who at the time is,
he's about to become the president.
He's supposed to get the fuck out of
there somewhere safe because they don't
know if there is,
if they,
if they didn't,
if they really believe there was more
than one shooter than he should have been
added there.
I mean,
I mean that's protocol.
He did not need to be there to get sworn
in that he could have done that a week
later.
It didn't matter.
But he,
he,
he kept his cool,
stuck around,
orchestrated a photo op on Air Force
One and being sworn in with Jackie,
Jackie o instead of getting,
getting out of there,
which didn't make sense.
Does have you,
yeah,
he probably knew.
He probably knew.
Hmm.
They killed him.
You know,
it's a dirty business.
It's like game of Thrones,
but it's in 1963 or 62 or
whatever it was when he died.
62 do you think it would be
harder to kill a president now?
Yeah,
it was.
Then we would have more,
but they could still do it.
They could still do it.
I'm surprised drones aren't
being used by other terror.
I mean,
you think about,
you know,
I don't know shit about it,
but you can go to a toy store and get
a helicopter that works with a remote
control and put it and put
a small explosive on it.
Now take that time,
somebody who can afford a
$20,000 version of that,
how hard it would be to kill
a president who's driving,
you know,
in a motorcade.
Yeah.
Well if you know those cars that they
have or bomb resistant and bullet
resistant,
you know,
it's not to say that you couldn't,
it would be hard to
get through those cars.
But what about a speech that you'd have
to find something where he's outdoors
and I mean,
it's possible someone,
someone could probably figure out a way
with technology to get to a president.
You know,
I'm just surprised you don't
see more than one has done it.
Thank God.
Well,
maybe that's the future.
I mean,
what could we,
this,
this Boston thing,
what if this is the beginning?
I mean,
you know,
we've,
we've endured piece or we've enjoyed
peace rather in this country for the last
12 plus years.
Since September 11th you know,
or 11 years,
11 plus years.
So it's not,
you know,
it's not outside the realm of possibility
that this is the beginning of some new
era where shit like this happened.
It's all gone.
It's going to happen.
I'd go back to it.
The media will strengthen the cause of
people that do things like this by making
it a hotter story than it needs
to be for the wrong reasons.
Yeah.
Do you think that that's an unavoidable
that one day there'll be able to figure
out how to not do that?
I,
it's hard to imagine because it seems
like it's gotten worse with that
more outlets.
There's more people competing for a story
so people are willing to do anything
to get a story
and culturally it's like how far do we
have to evolve before these things like
mass bombings and deaths and you know
the fucking tower shooters where that
never happens anymore.
Is that a possibility that we've
got to reach a 0.1 day where,
I mean there's a lot of shit that we
don't do anymore pretty much across the
board.
But if you get,
is there a point ever we can get to at
least in a country by country basis where
you can completely eradicate that shit.
Terrorism all tell her anything
ridiculous like that and mass murder,
as long as there is a force
of people that's weaker,
uh,
that has no voice and has
no say and they want to,
you know,
you look at with the Palestinians
did and Munich in 1972,
you know,
they were nothing.
People were fucking completely
ignoring them and then they,
uh,
they,
they blew some shit up and all of a
sudden they were on the map and they,
you know,
but isn't it a an odd,
we are almost willing.
The reason why I asked the question I
asked it before many people really is
because we're willing to accept the idea
that we're never going to get our shit
together.
You know,
like I'll,
I'll say,
is it possible there will be
a day where there's no war
people like no,
no friends on the definition of war,
while any,
okay.
Any violence whatsoever
amongst human beings like the,
if the reality of this room,
okay,
let's look at it this way.
If there's four of us and we,
you know,
we are the only people
left on this planet,
what are the odds that we'll go to war?
It's 100% that we won't,
you know,
I'm not going to go to war.
You're not going to go to war.
He's not going to go to war.
He's not going to go to or where you know,
at the very least we're going to be like,
well,
fuck you man.
I'm gonna go.
I'll see ya.
And that's the end.
Is that going to be any
limited amount of food?
Yeah.
Well that's when things get sketchy.
But is that really what's going on?
No,
it's been so weird.
Creepy Battle of resources
and hogging the re.
But point being,
we're not willing to ever conceive of of
an even a possibility of one day where
people no longer have any crime,
no longer have any war,
no longer have any murder,
no hate crimes,
no racism.
It's all gone.
It's gone in your life.
Greg Fitzsimmons is racism free,
your hate free violence free.
You're a nice guy.
You know,
like you,
you,
if their world was all
just Greg Fitzsimmons,
there would be no crime in the world to,
it'd be no war in the world.
But we're,
none of us are willing to even conceive
of the possibility of that existing know
as a,
as a rule amongst humans,
it's like,
Eh,
it's probably not going to ever happen
cause we can't stop everything
that happened before.
I mean,
most violence is a reaction
to previous violence.
You know,
most terrorist organizations have had
suffered something in the past that
they're trying to right a wrong,
you know,
whether it's the IRA or you know,
the Palestinians,
it's,
it's basically,
um,
a guy will fight you because he got
beat up when he was a kid by his father.
So now he's violent.
So it's almost like,
how do you start over?
How do you stop it all and just say,
okay,
clean slate.
No violence.
Mushrooms.
There you go.
I'm going to get them all on mushrooms,
Greg.
Fuck yeah.
The whole world.
Yeah.
That's your job.
I can get me on him.
I mean,
it's baby steps,
right?
Baby steps.
Indeed.
Tell.
Tell the the fine people
where they can find you.
Greg Fitzsimmons Simmons will be,
uh,
at the,
monsoon comedy festival.
Moontower comedy festival in Austin,
Texas.
That's coming up next week.
Cap City.
It's sunny there.
April,
uh,
24 through 27.
And then I will be,
I gotta be at the Ice House in Pasadena
coming up in May for the first time.
I've never really worked there.
I've hung out with you guys there,
but uh,
I'm going to,
I'm going to go do it.
That's going to be on the 18th of May.
Come in that week.
We'll pump it up.
Oh,
that'd be great.
Yeah,
let's do that.
And then obviously if you,
uh,
if you are in the mood and
you think it might help,
uh,
come,
come see me in Boston at Nick's
comedy stop this weekend.
And uh,
and if you're not,
then my thoughts and prayers are
with all the people in Boston.
And um,
you know,
well,
mine's pretty amazing.
Going back to Nick's.
That's uh,
that's fucking old school for us.
Literally the first stage that as stitches
and next for the first stage as we
ever did stand out.
Yeah,
that's a,
we saw some wild shit there.
You and I saw bill Hicks bomb and clear
the room and that place right while we
were howling laughing.
Yeah.
He literally cleared.
He went on after the comic
on a Harley Larry Nelson.
Remember he went up,
killed Hicks goes on and just,
it's just people are just getting up and
full tables and leaving and he's doing
this bit where Oprah Winfrey,
John Davidson gets fucked in the
ass by Satan and Satan shoots his,
his,
his demon load into John
Davidson and John Davidson from,
that's incredible.
The TV show swells up in the off
season and he shits out Geraldo Rivera.
Do you remember?
He's like,
cause the devil fucked him in the ass.
So Hicks is doing this bit or he's like
bent over like he's taking a shit and
he's grunting and groaning
like is shifting for like
minutes and he just looks
up as people just getting up and leaving.
He goes,
Yup.
That usually clears the room and you,
that's exactly how you were
somebody you just through your head.
I'm not,
that's my memory of that
day is you laughing at Hicks
saying that usually clears
the room.
It was like maybe us at the end of it all.
I mean,
how many just nick seat.
What's the two 50 so it was probably
almost totally packed when Hicks went on
stage,
by the time it was over,
there's like 50 people in
the audience and 10 comics
pissed that people were laughing at the
comics that went ahead of him cause he
thought there were so bad
that he had an agenda.
He was never,
there was never a goal to make them laugh.
No,
no,
it was he,
you know,
he was upset and he was,
he was also,
you know,
sort of trying to,
like,
it was trying to make a statement.
He was in a bad spot.
He used to bomb a lot around that time.
I think it was angry.
I Dunno what was going
on with his drinking,
but he was not up killing
night after night.
Well,
it was,
it was interesting.
It's interesting to watch it,
but it was also interesting to see a guy
who really actually didn't give a fuck.
Not a guy who wasn't pretending.
Right.
Guys per day.
I don't care.
I ain't getting paid either.
Whether you laugh at night,
but we saw the real,
the real person,
exactly what it was.
He truly did not fund it.
Not if there was one
percentage of him that cared,
the whole thing would have
fallen down like a hall.
Yeah.
House of cards.
But he didn't care.
He didn't care.
It was a fascinating to watch.
You know,
we got real lucky.
That's Nick's this weekend,
right?
You're going to be there.
That's it.
I'll be there.
And then Fitz dog radio.
Is The podcast powerful?
Correct.
He's Fitzsimmons.
Um,
and uh,
Brian,
uh,
what is the,
the dates and Sacramento
and San Francisco again?
Uh,
it's May 3rd and fourth,
which is a Friday and Saturday.
And then May 5th in San Francisco.
So San Sacramento,
May 3rd and fourth,
both great places.
Sacramento,
the punchlines fucking awesome.
That's another perfect comedy
club and Cobbs is amazing as well.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
that's it.
Thanks to stamps.com for
sponsoring the podcast.
You use the code name j e
and get yourself a super duper
bonus office bonus office.
Honest offer,
this special offer.
I'm not office $110 value.
Go get it.
You frogs.
Um,
thanks.
Also to [inaudible] dot com use the code
named Rogan and save yourself 10% off
any and all supplements.
All right,
we will see you guys next week.
Most likely.
I don't think I'll have time
to do another one this week.
I'm,
uh,
I'm working man for next couple of weeks.
So,
uh,
we love the fuck out of
you and we'll see you soon.
Take care.